WELL TO THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE HEARING. A
FEW REMINDERS MASKS ARE NOT
REQUIRED BUT ARE ENCOURAGE WHILE
YOU'RE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
OTHER COMMON AREAS THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL. TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON AND BY PHONE
THE NUMBER FOR PHONE TESTIMONY
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN. THIS
NUMBER IS ALSO POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND THE
VIDEO FEED ONCE THE PRIMARY
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
HAVE TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR
PHONE TESTIMONY. WE HAVE
NINETEEN MEASURES ON THE AGENDA
TODAY. PLEASE NOTE THAT AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY- BY MURDER SU
CHI AND AB TWENTY ONE FORTY ONE
EDUARDO GARCIA. HAVE BEEN PULLED
FROM TODAY'S HEARING. BOTH BILLS
WILL BE AMENDED AND SET FOR
APRIL TWENTY FIFTH. WE HAVE SIX
CONSENT ITEMS FOR THIS HEARING.
THEY ARE AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWO BY GRAYSON AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY NINE IRWIN. AB TWENTY
ONE OH ONE FLORA AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY TWO FLORA. AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY FIVE BY THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE AND AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SIX BY THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE- WE
ARE READY TO GET STARTED I THINK
. OF MISS AGUIAR-CURRY. DO WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY SO WE
WILL OPERATE AS A SUB COMMITTEE
UNTIL WE HAVE A QUORUM. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY RIGHT. ABOUT IT.
SOMEONE OKAY YEAH LET'S SEE DO I
HAVE IT- I THINK TRIED AGAIN I
GUESS MY VOICE IF YOU HAVE
NOTICED- OH SORRY MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES FIRST AND
FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK
ON THIS BILL I WILL NEXT BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL ADDRESS THE
NEED TO REMOVE FOREST BIOMASS
WASTE TO REDUCE WILDFIRES AND
CREATE HEALTHIER FOREST BY
PRIORITIZING STATE AGENCY USE OF
AND FOCUS ON THE PROCESSING OF
BIOMASS WASTE INTO BIO ENERGY
AND OTHER WOOD PRODUCTS. MEMBERS
I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR. THAT
THIS IS THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
GASIFICATION NOT COMBUSTIBLE OF
COMBUSTION OF BIOMASS. BIOMASS
GASIFICATION IS A MATURE
TECHNOLOGY PATH- THAT USES THE
CONTROL PROCESS INVOLVING HEAT
STEAM AND OXYGEN TO CONVERT
BIOMASS TO HYDROGEN AND OTHER
PRODUCTS WITHOUT COMBUSTION. IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY ADOPTED THE OF
FOREST BIOMASS UTILIZATION PLAN
ACCORDING TO THIS PLAN FOR
SPENDING IN CALIFORNIA WILL
GENERATE TEN TO FIFTEEN MILLION
TONS OF FOREST BIOMASS WASTE IN
ANNUALLY. BUT THAT WASTE IS
DISPOSED OF THROUGH PILE AND
BURN IT WILL EMIT ENORMOUS
AMOUNTS OF CLIMATE NEVER PRODUCE
POLLUTION. IT IS LEFT TO DECAY
IT WILL THE MILK MET EMIT
METHANE IT CLIMATE SUPER
POLLUTANT AND CONTINUE TO POSE A
FIRE THROUGHOUT. IT ALONE IN A
TWENTY TWENTY ALONE CALIFORNIA'S
WILDFIRES BURNED OVER FORTY
MILLION ACRES AND RELEASED OVER
NINETY MILLION METRIC TONS OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION ACRES BURNED LAST YEAR.
EMISSIONS FROM THESE WILDFIRES
UNDERCUT MUCH OF THE STATE'S
PROGRESS IN REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND RESULT IN
WIDESPREAD HAZARDOUS AIR QUALITY
FOR EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME.
THE CALIFORNIA FOREST CARBON
PLAN ADOPTED BY CAL EPA AND THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY FOUND THAT CONVERTING
THAT FORCE WASTE AND ENERGY CAN
CUT CLIMATE AND AIR POLLUTION BY
98% COMPARED TO OPEN BURNING.
HOWEVER NOT ONLY WILL THIS BILL
HELP REDUCE FUTURE EMISSIONS
RELATED TO THE OPEN BURNING OR
NOT SHOULD BE COMPOSED TO BECOME
POSITIONS USING A FOREST
RESIDUALS. BUT IT WILL ALSO
INCREASE ENERGY RELIABILITY AND
RESILIENCY IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AT GREATEST RISK OF LOSING POWER
AND CREATE JOBS AND IMPROVE THE
ECONOMY AND MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
RURAL COMMUNITIES. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY ARE THE CO
SPONSORS CRISTINA CHRISTIANITY
EARLY TEN ON BEHALF OF THE
PLASTER COUNTY BY THEIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT AND
JOHN KENNEDY ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU BEFORE WE
CONTINUE I WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
TAKE ROLE SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM
. JERRY HERE RIVAS HERE FLOOR
HERE LARA HERE FOR. HERE FOR
HERE. GARCIA MATHIS MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI. SEYARTO HERE SAY ARE
TO HERE STONE STONE HERE WOULD
YOU CLICK HERE WE HAVE A POINT
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM- SO WE
HAVE TO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH MYSTARA INTENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY NAME IS CRISTIAN A
DARLINGTON AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE PLASTER AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT OUR
DISTRICT IS SPONSORING ITS FIRST
BILL IN THE HISTORY OF THE AIR
DISTRICT WITH THIS IS JUST WITH
THE SPILL WE FIND THIS TO A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR OVER FIFTEEN
YEARS TO BRING ATTENTION TO THE
FACT THAT FOREST BIOMASS WASTE
CONTRIBUTES A LOT TOWARDS OUR
AIR POLLUTION. IT DOES WHEN IT
DECAYS IT EMITS METHANE WHEN
IT'S LEFT ON THE FLOOR AND BUT
MOST OFTEN IT'S DISPOSED OF
THREE PILUM BURNING WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT COULD CONTRIBUTION
TO AIR POLLUTION ESPECIALLY PM
TWO FIVE WHICH HAS A VERY
SERIOUS HEALTH EFFECTS THERE'S A
RECENT STUDY THAT HAS COME OUT
FROM UC SAN DIEGO JUST LAST YEAR
THAT SHOWING THAT PM TWO POINT
FIVE FROM WILDFIRES IS ACTUALLY
MUCH WORSE FOR OUR HEALTH THAN
OTHER TYPES OF PM SO WE NEED TO
PAY EXTRA SPECIAL ATTENTION TO
THE PM THAT'S COMING OUT FROM
WILDFIRES ADDITIONALLY THE BLACK
CARBON THAT'S EMITTED FROM
WILDFIRES IS A CARBON FORCING
AGENT WHICH IS HUNDREDS OF TIMES
MORE POTENT. THAN CO TWO ALONE
SO FOR BOTH OF THOSE REASONS AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICTS TAKE
VERY SERIOUSLY THE BIOMASS
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE THAT YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT- FROM THE AUTHOR.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
PUT OUT THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
THIS. GET WITH PLANS THEY
ALREADY HAVE AND THEY'VE ALREADY
INVESTED A LOT OF MAN HOURS AND
TIME AND FINANCE INTO THESE
PLANS. BUT THEY NEED HELP TO GET
ORGANIZED AND PUT THESE PLANS
INTO ACTION. THIS SPECIFICALLY
IS CREATING A NEW PROGRAM AT THE
JOINT WOULD INSTITUTE FOR WOOD
PRODUCTS AT THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY. AS WELL AS
IMPLEMENTING BLACK CARBON
RESEARCH INTO THE FOREST CARBON
PLAN. AND THEN INCORPORATING
THAT INTO THE SCOPING PLAN. AND
THEN ADDITIONALLY LOOKING AT
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH ON BLACK
CARBON IN THE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLAN THAT YOU.
REQUIRE THEM DEBT CARD TO PUT
TOGETHER A THREE SB NINE A ONE.
SO WHAT THIS REALLY IS A
COLLABORATION OF EFFORTS TO GET
THE STATE ORGANIZED. AND WILL
HOPE THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER VOTING
FOR THE BILL. THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER KENNEDY ALL
RIGHT JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE VERY PLEASED
TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL HERE
TODAY WITH PLASTER COUNTY-
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT. WE
REPRESENT THIRTY NINE WORLD
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES MOST OF WHOM
HAVE BEEN HIT REALLY HARD BY
WILDFIRES OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. BUT MANY OF WHOM ALSO
HAVE EXPERIENCED A REAL DOWNTURN
IN ENERGY RELIABILITY- UP WERE
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT TODAY
BECAUSE IT TAKES A REAL MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH. TO FIND
PRODUCTIVE USES FOR RESIDUAL
FORCE WASTE THAT'S OUT THERE AND
WILL DECOMPOSE NATURALLY IT WILL
BE BURNED. THIS DOES IT THROUGH
BOTH ENERGY PRODUCTION AND WOOD
PRODUCTS MANUFACTURING. AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT
FACILITATES WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION IN FORCE HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT IMPROVES LOCAL
ENERGY RELIABILITY ENHANCES
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. AND HELPS
PROTECT FAMILIES WHO WERE LIVING
IN THE WHAT WE- SO WITH RESPECT
TO WILDFIRE RISK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SUMMED IT UP PRETTY WELL.
ESPECIALLY THE SHEER NUMBER OF
ACRES BURNED AND THE- GHG
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH FIRES
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
REMOVING THESE RESIDUAL FUELS
FROM THE FORCED WILL HELP REDUCE
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
MANAGEMENT OF THOSE MATERIALS.
IMPORTANTLY TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT ALSO HELPS TO ALIGN THE
STATE'S AB THIRTY TWO SCOPING
PLAN. WITH THE STATE'S FOREST
CARBON PLAN BOTH OF THOSE SEEM
TO BE MOVING FORWARD ON
PARALLELS. IS TODAY BUT WITHOUT
THE LEVEL OF COORDINATION IS
REQUIRED TO GET US TO WHERE WE
NEED TO GET IN THE FUTURE.
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY IT ALSO
PROMOTES LOCAL ENERGY
RELIABILITY FOSTERING THE USE OF
BIO ENERGY TO POWER WORLD MICRO
GRIDS AND FORCED IT COMMUNITIES.
HELPING BIOENERGY PROJECTS
INTERCONNECT WITH THE GRIT AND
EXTENDING TE STATE'S BIOMET
PROGRAM TO TWENTY THIRTY. THESE
CAN HELP SOME OF THE MOST- AT
RISK COMMUNITIES OF ELECTRICAL
OUTAGES OFFSET THE NEED TO RUN
MORE ONE OR MORE DIESEL
GENERATORS DURING THE OUTAGES
THAT SEEM TO BE OCCURRING MORE
AND MORE OFTEN. AND THEN FINALLY
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY WILL
HELP THE STATE ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS BY DEVELOPING A WORKFORCE.
TRAINING PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
OUR WORK FORCE CAN MEET THE
CURRENT AND FUTURE NEEDS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR AYE BUT TODAY.
THANK YOU- WE DON'T ANY WITNESS
REGISTER IN OPPOSITION SO WE'LL
MOVE ALONG TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION STARTING WITH THOSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. TO THE ELEVEN OF THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT. PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU- I'LL
OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS- MISTER
WHAT. YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND SAY THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR-
WE- WE SHARE A PASSION FOR THIS
ISSUE- I THINK IN THE PAST WE'VE
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT WELL
THIS IS AN AND IS THIS ISN'T IT.
EFFICIENT WAY TO PRODUCE ENERGY
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS BUT
THIS IS A DIFFERENT THIS IS A
DIFFERENT APPROACH AND I THINK
AND I THINK IT'S WELL WELL WORTH
WHAT WHAT WITH WHAT YOU'RE
DOING. IS REALLY ABOUT OUR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THIS WASTE PRODUCT
THAT'S IN THE FORCE THERE- SO
THAT WE HAVE TO DECIDE DO WE
WANT A BIG MASSIVE FIRE ORDER
WEEK CAN WE LOOK AT WAYS TO
MINIMIZE THAT BY HOW WE DEAL
WITH THIS- WITH THIS WASTE THESE
WASTE PRODUCTS AND THREW
SOMETHING THAT PROVIDES A AT A
BENEFIT ON THE ON THE OTHER END.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE EVER
PROBABLY BE FINANCIALLY THE BEST
WAY TO PRODUCE ENERGY BUT BUT IT
IS I THINK IT'S MORE OF A SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT US
FROM THE POLLUTION WE KNOW THAT
HAPPENS WE HAVE THESE MASSIVE
WILDFIRES SO I WOULD HAVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF IF THE
BILL PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE AND
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT
FORTH. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. MISTER MATHIS. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR THEY TO THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. MISTER WAS ISN'T THE
ONLY ONE THAT SHARES A-
APPRECIATION OF BIOMASS YOU KNOW
I THINK THE REALITY OF IT IS.
YOU GOTTA TAKE THE MATERIAL OUT
OF THE FOREST NUMBER. WHAT ARE
YOU GONNA DO WITH IT I GALLAGHER
SAID ROT I GET A LOT OF BURN. OR
CAN YOU TAKE IT AND CREATE A
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOURCE. I THINK
THE OPTIONS PRETTY CLEAR. SO I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING I'D
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A JOINT
AUTHORS SHOW BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR THE MEASURE IF YOU HAVE ME
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. OKAY THANK
YOU- I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY BUT I HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY MOTION BY- DOCTOR WITH
SECOND BY MISTER MATHIS
SECRETARY Q. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO UTILITIES AND ENERGY
CHAIR THIS HI RIVAS HI FLORA.
FLORA HI BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I FREED FRIEDMAN
GARCIA MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
AYE MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
SEYARTO HI SEE ARE SO AYE STONE
. STONE I WOULD. WHAT HI. CAN
BILL HAS A BOTH- BUT WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
TO THANK YOU VERY MEMBERS VERY
MUCH MEMBERS. NEXT CALL. I DON'T
SEE HER. SHE'S HERE- I DON'T.
GALLAGHER IF NOT ALL TAKE OFF
WORK WE OF IS HERE. GARCIA
MISTER. YEAH THAT'S I DON'T.
EIGHT TWENTY SIX ZERO ONE BY-
EDUARDO GARCIA MISTER EDUARDO
GARCIA THANK YOU MR AND
COLLEAGUES AB BOSTON BASED OFF
BY TAKING YOUR TEAM FOR THE
ANALYSIS PUT FORWARD AB TWENTY
SIX OH ONE WERE PROHIBITED
REGIONAL BOARD FROM MISSION A
WASTEWATER DISCHARGE PERMIT FOR
NEW DAM FILL OR A LATERAL
EXPANSION OF AN EXISTING
LANDFILL THAT IS USED FOR THE
DISPOSAL OF NON HAZARDOUS SOLID
WASTE. WITHIN THREE MILES OF THE
MEXICAN BORDER RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. I THINK WE DO
HAVE A WITNESS THAT WAS GOING TO
BE CALLING AND- IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN. THAT IS CORRECT I'M
SORRY YOUR VARGAS OKAY SO WE-
OPERATOR WE HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT- SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR NORA VARGAS. YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR HER
. WE ARE LOOKING FOR HER LINE
RIGHT NOW MOVES THE BILL. HELLO
YES THE SUPERVISOR VARGAS. YEAH
THIS IS A MULTI FACTOR FROM
OFFICE THE VICE CHAIR PARKING
OKAY IT'S NOT AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE TODAY YEAH IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
THEM TO A BILL SIX ONE. EIGHTY
SIX A ONE EIGHT IMPORT FOR THE
HEALTH OF THE MONEY FOR OF THE
ACCOUNTING ESPECIALLY THE THAT
LIVE DISTRICTS. TO DISTRICT BUT
THE U. S. FOR KERR WITH MY- I AM
THRILLED. AMONG SOCIETY MOST
IMPROPER. MAN YOU. AS THE NEW.
LONG THAT ARE IN THE RESTRICTING
THEIR- THEY'RE GETTING TO BE
DIFFERENT THAN FROM HOME.
ANOTHER CONCERT OF AREA. ARE
IMPORTANT TO US. HOW LET'S SEE
WHAT THE CURRENT ATTRACTIVE. HOW
FOR. PROPOSED LAND BUILDING. OF
CONCERN NEAR THE U. S. MEXICO-
DR. ARE REGION IS PREDOMINANTLY
. LATINO CLASS. FAMILIES THAT
ARE HISTORICALLY UNDER THIRD. IN
THEY'RE ALL. IMPACTED WITH
TWENTY FOUR. I THINK THE OF.
LEADING CROP THE BORDER OF ENTRY
. IT FOR THEM TO HUGE CHAO. THAT
HEALTH AND LOCAL PAUL. SO AT THE. IN IN OUR OPINION ENVIRONMENT
AND WRONG CONSTANTLY ALLOW. THAT
THE MOST FOOD LANXESS I CONTINUE
IN THE- AB TWENTY SIX SO WHY
MORE PART THE POOR COMMUNITY
FROM BEING FURTHER. WITH MORE F.
MORE GRAVEL POLLUTION AND MARK
TRAFFIC. AND IT WILL ALSO HELP
ENSURE THAT THE TRUCK DEFENDER
RIVER VALLEY IT'S NOT THEIR FOOD
. YOUNG CURRENTLY AND A CONSISTS
WITH OUR PAYMENT OPTIONS. BUT I
THINK IT'S MEMBER THE EFFORT TO
KEEPING THEMSELVES- YOU KNOW IF
TIME FOR THE LAW TO PROTECT THE
BORDER COMMUNITY FROM A- OF THE
- IN BETWEEN GOT IT FOR FIRST.
AND OTHER WHEN USES. FOR THOSE
REASONS I YOUR SUPPORT FOR
TWENTY AT ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HAVE NEXT ALREADY FOR WITH
. IN SUPPORT OP ADDITIONAL. AND
SUPPORTERS. START IN THE HEARING
ROOM. YOU SEE NINE OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR A DISH
WEIGHT AND OR OPPOSITION. OF AB
TWENTY SO ONE. FOR CALM SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX
OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. SIX COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM
LINE TWENTY ONE. MICHAEL GREEN
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE REPORT. ED MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE COMMENTS MISS BERMAN
I JUST LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING THIS WORD IT'S A VERY
BIG ISSUE IN OUR BORDER REGION
AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR AS YOU AFFORD. TO
HEY. I'M SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND- MISTER GARCIA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. JUST THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR LAWMAKERS AND
DISPEL BEHALF OF- THE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE THEY LIVE ADJACENT TO
THE BORDER WHO SUFFER EVERY DAY
FROM A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
APARTMENT JUST AS ISSUES AND- TO
REASON WHY THESE BILLS BEFORE
YOU SO THANK YOU RESPECT US FOR
RIVAL. THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION
IS. DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL JERRY THIS
HI. RIVAS I FLORA. FLORA NO
BOERNER HORVATH. BOERNER HORVATH
I FRIEDMAN. GARCIA MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY. MCCARTY ARMOR
TO. SEYARTO YEAH HERE TO KNOW
STONE. STONE I WOULD. WE I. THE
BILL HAS FIVE BOTH SO IT'S ON
CALL- WE'LL WAIT WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON CALL RIGHT FIVE VOTES FIVE.
OKAY WE HAVE A MO TO MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IN THE SECOND.
HE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. JERRY
THIS I REQUEST I. FLORA. FLORA
FIVE BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI FRIEDMAN
GARCIA MATHIS- MATHIS AND
MCCARTY. MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
SEYARTO HI C. A. R. TO AYE STONE
STONE I WOULD. WOOD I HEY WE
WILL MOVE BACK ON HOW MANY. YEAH
OKAY THE CONTENT OUT- HAS EIGHT
WERE LEAVE IT OPEN MEMBERS THAT
ARE MISSING NEXT WE'LL MOVE BACK
TO ITEM THREE. AB. TWO FOUR FOUR
FIVE FIVE MR GALLAGHER WHO WILL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWO FOUR FOUR FIVE
pIN THE CHAIR. AND THE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. AB TWO
FOUR FOUR FIVE AUTHORED CO
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON- WOULD ALLOW A JUDGE TO
REQUIRE BONDS FOR PARTIES FILING
SEQUEL LAWSUITS. AGAINST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS-
THIS BOMB WILL COVER THE COSTS
AND DAMAGES INCURRED BY THE
RESPONDENT BECAUSE OF A DELAY.
IN THE PROJECT. SEQUELS OFTEN
ENFORCED BY AGGRIEVED PARTIES
REQUESTING THAT A COURT MANDATE
OR EITHER A EITHER A FULL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. IN CASES
WHERE NONE WAS INITIALLY DEEMED
NECESSARY OR HEAVILY REVISIONS-
WERE MADE TO AN EXISTING THE I.
R. SOMETIMES IT CAN SCAN FILE
THESE LAWSUITS ANONYMOUSLY. IN
THEORY THE SYSTEM WAS MEANT TO
PROTECT THOSE MOST AFFECTED BY
THE PROPOSED PROJECTS. BUT IN
PRACTICE WE'VE SEEN MANY
INSTANCES WHERE SEEK WAS BEEN
USED. BY NIMBYS TO STOP PROJECTS
OR DELAY PROJECTS- THIS WOULD
JUST REQUIRE AT LEAST TO BE SOME
SKIN IN THE GAME THAT YOU THAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO HAVE A BONDING
REQUIREMENT- THAT ENSURES THAT.
YOU KNOW IF THE IF THIS IS A
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT IF THERE IS
NOTHING NO MERIT TO IT. THAT
THERE IS THE BOND THEIR TO HELP.
INSURE THE DAMAGES TO THE IT
RESPONDED OR ARE TAKING CARE OF-
SO. YOUR OPPOSE THIS AS A JUST A
REASONABLE REFORM- TO OUR SEQUEL
LAWS TO ENSURE THAT IS YOU KNOW
THESE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT WE NEED AND- AND
THAT WE HAVE AND ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS AREN'T UNDULY. DELAYED
OR STOPPED- BECAUSE OF A
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT AND AS I WOULD
ASK FOR THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT I
DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES- IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WITH ME
TODAY- FIRST IS MAUREEN. SIT
DOWN AND SIT DOWN IN HIS THE CEO
OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY GREATER
SAN FRANCISCO AND ALSO ON THE
PHONE I HAVE ANDREW SAVVY
ATTORNEY WITH EVEN HOUSING. OKAY
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT INTRINSIC
NOT EVERYBODY GETS THAT INTRO
MUSIC. BUT WILL START. I'LL TAKE
THAT AS A SIGN YES IT'S OKAY SO
ALL THAT WILL START MS SEDONA
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD A
RIVAS AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MAUREEN SIT DOWN AND I'M THE CEO
OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY GREATER
SAN FRANCISCO IN THE FOR CHAIR
OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION MADE UP
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS OUR GREAT
STATE. I'M HERE TODAY TO
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT AB TWO
FOUR FIVE AND THE COURAGEOUS
EFFORTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GALLAGHER GRAYSON TO LESSEN THE
SEVERE IMPACT CIVIL LAWSUITS
HAVE ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HABITAT
GREATER SAN FRANCISCO WAS BUILT
A TWENTY HOME 1100% AFFORDABLE
DEVELOPMENT AND REDWOOD CITY BUT
IS NOW NEARLY COMPLETE TWENTY
VERY EXCITED FAMILIES ALL FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS WHO ALL DID
THEIR FIVE HUNDRED HOURS OF
SWEAT EQUITY. ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF PURCHASING AND WILL SOON MOVE
IN AND BEGIN THEIR HOMEOWNERSHIP
JOURNEY IN THEIR HABITAT HOMES
BUT THE HARSH REALITY IS THEY
SHOULD HAVE ALREADY MOVED IN
YEARS AGO FOR NEARLY SIXTEEN
MONTHS THE DEVELOPMENT WAS
NEEDLESSLY STALLED AFTER
APPROVAL WELL WE FOUGHT A
COMPLETELY BASELESS SEQUEL
LAWSUIT BROUGHT FORTH BY A
NEIGHBOR WHO HAD HIS BUSINESS
NEXT DOOR THAT IRONICALLY USED
TO BE HOUSING. WELL WE DIDN'T
LIVE HE DIDN'T LIVE IN REDWOOD
CITY HE WAS ADMITTEDLY ANGRY AT
THE CITY FOR ALL OF THE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE DOWNTOWN
DESPITE THE FACT THAT IT WAS
COMPLETELY IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE CITY SPECIFIC PLAN AND ALL
OF THE LOCAL BUSINESS BUILDING
GUIDELINES THIS LOCAL BUSINESS
HAD A TRACK RECORD OF INITIATING
SICKLE EDUCATION AND DOING
ANYTHING THEY COULD TO STOP
PROJECTS IN THE CITY. THIS
HAPPENED EVEN THOUGH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF THE
PROJECT HAD ALREADY BEEN
METICULOUSLY REVIEWED AND
UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED BY BOTH THE
PLANNING COMMISSION AND THE CITY
COUNCIL IN ADDITION TO THE YEARS
OF DELAY THE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT COST REPORTS OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS THE STOCK WAS
IMPACTING OUR NONPROFIT'S
MISSION AND WITH NO RECOURSE NOR
ANY FINANCIAL RECOVERY FOR US
WHEN THE BASIL SPENCE WAS PROVEN
AND THIS MADE BY THIS MEAN
SPIRITED AND FALSE CLAIM. THIS
CASE WAS FILED AFTER WE HAD
ALREADY READ WORK TO REDUCE OUR
HOME COUNT FROM THIRTY SIX TO
TWENTY OWNS THE UNITS TO APPEASE
THE SAME NEIGHBORS WHO ARE
FIGHTING US AT STEP OF THE WAY
BEING AS BELOW AS HABITAT. IS
CARRYING OUT OUR UNIQUE MY OF A
HIGH PERCENT AFFORDABLE.
PROJECTS WE'RE- FORTUNATE
RECEIVE GENEROUS PRO BOWL LEGAL
SUPPORT. A COUPLE THIS WITH OUR
STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY
AND AN UNDERSTANDING AND SUPPORT
OF DONOR COMMUNITY. THAT HAS
ALLOWED US TO SETTLE THE CASE
BEFORE ANY LITIGATION AND MOVE
FOR WITH OUR PROJECT. HABITAT
KNOWS HOW IMPORTANT SECRET IS TO
MAINTAIN A PROTECT OUR STATE'S
BEAUTIFUL NATURAL BEAUTY. BUT
OUR EXPERIENCE ANY EXPERIENCE OF
HUNDREDS OF OTHERS DEMONSTRATES
HOW THE UNFAIR AND MISUSE
APPLICATION OF SEQUEL. ON THE
GROUND HAS A PARTIAL OFTEN
EXPENSIVE EFFECT ON THE ABILITY
OF ALL DEVELOPERS. THERE MUST BE
A BETTER WAY UNFORTUNATELY
DEVELOP PERSONAL DEVELOPMENTS
LIKE OURS AND OTHERS GET
DERAILED OR CANCELED ALTOGETHER.
AT A TIME WE ARE MILLIONS OF
UNITS SHORTEN OUR STATE. OF
MEETING THE DEMAND FOR ALL
HOUSING AND DESPERATE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. MISGUIDED
LITIGATION HAS A HIDDEN IMPACT
ON MORE ECONOMICALLY MARGINAL
PROJECTS THAT THAT DID NOT GET
OFF THE GROUND AT ALL. BECAUSE
THESE DEVELOPERS KNOW THE COULD
NOT FINANCIALLY SURVIVE EVEN A
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT. GIVEN
JUDICIAL OFFICERS THE AUTHORITY
TO REQUIRE A SINGLE PETITIONER
TO POST A BOND. COULD LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD AND HELP ENSURE
ONLY SERIOUS THREATS O OUR
ENVIRONMENT- BROUGHT FORWARD.
AND LIKELY WOULD DETERRENT
DISCOURAGE THESE MOST PRIVILEGED
SEQUEL LAWSUITS OFTEN SALLY
BROUGHT BY THOSE. LOOKING FOR A
PAYOUT. FROM SEEING THE LIGHT OF
DAY. THIS WOULD GIVE AFFORDABLE
HOME BUILDERS CONFIDENCE. FROM
THIS WORST EFFECTS OF THIS ABUSE
ONE WE'RE HERE TO FULFILL OUR
MISSION BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HELP SOLVE OUR STATE'S
UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING CRISIS.
HAVE A DECORATOR SAN FRANCISCO
AND HABITAT CALIFORNIA ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GRAYSON
GALLAGHER. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THIS COMMITTEE TO JOIN THEM AND
SUPPORT AB TWO FOUR FIVE. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE- ANDREW AB
TESTIFYING OVER THE PHONE.
OPERATOR CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
GREAT THANK YOU THAT THAT
INTRODUCED AB I'M A PARTNER IN
THE LAW FIRM OF PODCASTONE
NICHOLSON- AND I TYPICALLY
REPRESENT PROJECT APPLICANTS
INCLUDING- APPLICANTS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO DEFEAT IN
HOUSING AND WE'VE HAD A RECENT
EXPERIENCE WITH THEM- BEING THAT
OF A PRIVILEGE LAWSUIT THAT IF
THERE WERE THERAPY TO PROCEED
WITH A 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
PROJECT IN THE CITY OF LIVERMORE
AND LET THEIR FINANCING WINDOW
WHICH- IT'S HARD TO CALCULATE
THE DAMAGES BUT THEY HAD A SIXTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION THAT THEY'VE HAD TO
TURN BACK IN SOLELY AS THE
RESULT OF A OF THE CHECK WHICH
TO THAT IS HAS BEEN DENIED BUT
CAN BE APPEALED AND CONTINUE THE
DELAY- AND I THINK THE KEY
MESSAGES THAT THAT THE CHILLING
EFFECT OF THIS KIND OF
LITIGATION ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IT'S ACTUALLY. DIFFICULT TO
OVERSTATE THE CHILLING EFFECT OF
THAT- AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT
IN PARTICULAR ARE TYPICALLY AND
YOU KNOW HABITAT IS ONLY ONE
UNIQUE MODEL BUT THEY TYPICALLY.
RELY ON A VERY COMPLICATED
HEAVILY REGULATED AND
UNFORGIVING BANK FINANCING.
MECHANISMS THAT. IT JUST CANNOT
CALL THE THAT THE ASSOCIATE WITH
MEDICAID AND OPPONENTS WHICH
BEGS MAY BE UPON TO ARE PRETTY
SOPHISTICATED UNDER AND THEY
ALSO UNDERSTAND THE BIG BASS NO
WAY NO FINANCIAL. CONCERNS ALL
IN BRINGING THE AND BIG BOMB
MAKER A MODEST BUT I THINK
MEANINGFUL STEP- AS AND I WERE
DISCLOSE WHAT OTHER TIPS
LEVELING THE PLAYING. AND
ENSURING THE THOSE WHO THE SO OF
LOS CAPITAL IN THE TO SEE IT'S
NOT TOO THE AFFORD TO THE AND
LET'S FACE IT THE FOLKS WOULD
REALLY BENEFIT FROM THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHO WHO STAND
TO LOSE AND IT WOULD EMPOWER THE
COURTS. TO OVERSEE THESE ISSUES
THAT AND- IMPOSED SUBJECTS SO I
SAY COMMEND YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I'M NOT WE
HAVE ONE WITH- IN OP. A MISTER
GERMANY'S FOR THE STATE BUILDING
AND CAN TRADE COUNCIL. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S NICE TO BE BACK
IN FRONT OF ALL OF YOU IN
PERSON- GOOD TO SEE EVERYBODY
ALL THE WAY AROUND- I'M JEREMY
SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL- AND OPPOSITION
TO THIS LEGISLATION- YOU KNOW I
JUST TALKED TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER A FEW MINUTES AGO. I KNOW
THIS IS THE FIRST COMMITTEE- BUT
WE DID NOTE SOME OF SERIOUS
ISSUES WITH THE BILL AS WE READ
IT AS OUR TEAM AT AT AT THE AT
THE BUILDING TRDES- FIRST OF
ALL- THERE THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
DO NOT FIX THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN OUR LETTER-%
BECAUSE THE BILL STILL ALLOWS A
COURT. TO REQUIRE PLAINTIFFS TO
POST A BOND TO COVER COSTS AND
DAMAGES TO AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT WHICH AN AGENCY OR
DEVELOPER CLAIM THEY WANT KERR
AS A RESULT OF THE LAWSUIT.
WITHOUT SUPPORTING EVIDENCE.
THAT THE BILL WOULD ALSO CREATE
AN UNPRECEDENTED CHANGE A LAW TO
ALLOW THE TRIAL COURT TO REQUIRE
A SEQUEL PETITIONER TO POST A
BOND ON ITS OWN MOTION. WITHOUT
BEING ASKED FOR ONE BY ANY OF
THE PARTIES IN THE CASE- WE WILL
REVIEW THIS IS A VIOLATION OF
THE PETITIONERS DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS BY ALLOWING THE COURT TO
VOLUNTARILY TAKE SIDES WITH THE
DEVELOPER MYSTICAL CASE BEFORE
TRIAL. BEFORE REVIEWING THE
EVIDENCE FOR THE MERITS OF THE
CASE. IT WOULD ALSO BE A MAJOR
VIOLATION OF THE COURT'S DUTY TO
IMPARTIALITY IN OF THE COURTS TO
TEACH OF STAIN FROM RULING ON
SUBSTANTIVE MATTERS THAT THE
PARTIES HAVE NOT PLACED BEFORE
IT. FOR WE JUST BELIEVE THE BILL
IS UNNECESSARY BECAUSE EXISTING
LOT. CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE
FIVE TO NINE POINT TWO- ALREADY
ALLOWS DEFENDANTS TO ASK THE
COURT TO REQUIRE A BOND IF THE
COURT FINDS OF THE SEQUEL
LAWSUIT HAS THE EFFECT OF
PREVENTING. OR DELAYING AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT AND
I. WANTED TO CONCLUDE WITH-
REFERENCE BACK TO A TWENTY
TWENTY ONE STUDY BY THE ROSE
FOUNDATION. THERE'S FOUND THE
NUMBER OF LAWSUITS FILED UNDER
SPEAK WITH ABOUT CALIFORNIA. HAS
BEEN LOW AVERAGING. ONE HUNDRED
AND NINETY FIVE PER YEAR SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO. THIS
REPLICATION FOR CHALLENGES TO
PROJECTS ALLEGING NON COMPLIANCE
TO SEEK IT WAS ALSO VERY LOW
WITH LAWSUITS FILED. FOR TWO OUT
OF EVERY ONE HUNDRED PROJECTS.
WE DON'T THINK THERE'S A THERE
THERE- I THINK EVERYBODY IN THIS
ROOM. HAS A WORST CASE SCENARIO
LAWSUIT EXAMPLE. MANY OF YOU BUT
I'M ADDRESSING RIGHT NOW
PROBABLY HAVE MORE THAN ONE. YOU
PROBABLY HEAR FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ALL THE TIME. BUT
FOR ALL THE LAWSUITS FILED IN
CALIFORNIA SYKORA. IS LOW SEE
WHAT TEACHER LOW IN THAT SENSE.
SO WE'RE JUST NOT SURE THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY AND WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE CHANGE. TO
PROCESS IN THIS DELIGHT IT-
PLACES UPON PLAINTIFFS. WHO MANY
OF WHOM- WE THINK- HAVE VERY
VALID REASONS TO FILE LAWSUITS
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
OPPOSED TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU HAVE NEXT WILL MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION WILL START IN THE
HEARING ROOM. MADAM CHAIR HOLLY
FOR MANY DAYS USED WITH WHITE
HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE IN
SUPPORTING OF THE OFFICE BURDENS
AND HELP PROPERTIES. THANK YOU
CHEN MEMBERS THE HONESTY TODAY
WITH BROWN STEEN ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING ACTION COALITION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
KEY PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB TWO FOUR
FOUR FIVE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT EIGHT
B. TWO FOUR FOUR FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND WE
WILL START WITH LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL GUNNING HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY FIVE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS APERAM
REPRESENTING THE SEVEN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AN ALLIANCE TWENTY THREE. SH
JOSH AMERICANS THAT THE
RESIDENTS FOR RESPONSIBLE GROWTH
AND STRONG SUPPORT. SENATE MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. K. C. NINE-
WE HAVE A MOTION OF MISTER
VERSACE. THANK YOU UP MR
GALLAGHER. SO I THINK ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I'M HEARING IS
THAT THE BOND REQUIREMENT MIGHT-
BE HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT ON THE
BRINGING OF THE JUDGMENT SEQUEL
LAWSUITS COULD YOU CAN YOU
RESPOND TO THAT- WELL I THINK
WHAT THE WITNESS IS SAYING IS
THAT SEEK WAS HAVING A CHILLING
EFFECT ON. AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
BECAUSE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS YOU KNOW IF THEY'RE
GETTING CHALLENGE THEN. AND IT'S
GOING TO BE THAT COSTLY TO GO
THROUGH ALL THAT PROCESS THEN.
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE RISK LOSING
THEIR TAX CREDIT YOU KNOW LIKE
SO THE INSTANCE OF THE EXAMPLE
CITED IT WAS LIKE A SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR TAX CREDIT
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT PROJECT.
THEY'VE NOW HAD TO GIVE THAT
BACK NO I WRITE AND- I HEARD
THAT FROM YOUR WITNESS BUT- FROM
THE OPPOSITION I THOUGHT I
HEARD- READ IN THEIR OPPOSITION
LETTER THAT. MY ROLE MY RESPOND
LOOK I WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION- YOU KNOW AS HE
SAID WE JUST SPOKE- YOU KNOW AND
IF THE COMMITTEE DOES PASS IT
OUT TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH YOU
KNOW THOSE ISSUES. I DON'T I
DON'T FOR SEE A CHILLING EFFECT
BECAUSE AGAIN THIS ISN'T
STOPPING. MERITORIOUS LAWSUITS
IF THERE'S A LEGITIMATE- SEQUEL
LAWSUIT BROUGHT ON. OUR MENTAL
IMPACTS BECAUSE THE PROJECT
WHICH IS ASSOCIATED WITH LABOR.
WORK FORCE. YOU CAN STILL BRING
THOSE FORD AND THERE MAY NOT
EVEN BE A THE RIVER. IN THOSE
CASES GO AGAIN THIS MAY. DOESN'T
SAY SHE- SO. BUT IT IS TRYING TO
GET OUT WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN IN.
REALLY EVERY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS PEOPLE
TRYING TO BRING FORWARD GOOD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS AND
SORT OF A NIMBY LAWSUIT IS
BROUGHT THAT DOESN'T HAVE A LOT
OF. YOU KNOW MERIT TWO AWARDS AT
LEAST THE COURT HAS THE ABILITY
TO. ISSUE A BONDING REQUIREMENT
TO SAY LOOK IF YOU'RE NOT
SUCCESSFUL AND IT'S FOUND THAT
THIS IS. NOT A MERITORIOUS CLAIM
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING TO COVER
THE LOSSES TO. THE RESPONDENT.
YOU KNOW AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
AGAIN IT IS LIMITED TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS SO
BASED ON THAT I MEAN IS THERE
SOME TRUTH TO WHAT. MISTER SMITH
OF THE BUILDING TRADES AS SAYING
THAT. THE JUDGE IS BEING ASKED
TO KIND OF LIKE PRE JUDGE. THE
FACTS OF THE CASE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT- ON HIS HER OWN
MOTION. WHETHER A BOND IS. IS
JUSTIFIED WELL IT'S NOT REALLY
PRE JUDGING IT I MEAN WE SEEN
THIS AND OTHER CASES LIKE
PRELIMINARY INJUNCTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE OR- WHERE THERE IS.
REQUIREMENTS IF YOU'RE GONNA GET
THIS THAT YOU HAVE TO PUT UP A
BOND. RIGHT IT'S NOT. AND IT'S
YOU KNOW USUALLY A BOND IS NOT
LIKE THE FULL AMOUNT RIGHT IT'S
YOU'RE PAYING A PORTION AND THE
BOND IS PLACE FOR THE COURT- IT
JUST PUTS THAT UP THERE IS A HEY
LOOK IF IN FACT- YOU KNOW THIS
IS NOT A MERITORIOUS CLAIM
THERE'S SOMETHING TO. ACCOUNT
FOR THAT AND I WILL LOOK IT DOES
REQUIRE AT LEAST YOU TO HAVE
SOME. SOME SKIN IN THE GAME- YOU
KNOW HAVE A REALLY STRONG BELIEF
IN THAT YOUR CASE IS A OF YOU
KNOW LEGITIMATE ONE BEFORE
YOU'RE BRINGING IT. AGAINST AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT.
THANK YOU. MR STONE. THIS THANK
YOU WANNA MAKE A COMMENT TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY A RESTATEMENT OF
EXISTING LAW WHICH I DON'T FIND
OFFENSIVE THE THERE IS A BIT OF
AN ADDITION THAT DOES ALLOW THE
COURT ON ITS OWN MOTION WHICH I
DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND HERE BUT
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT. I THINK
WILL BE ADDRESSED IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MR MCCARTY.
YEAH THANK YOU I'M I'M ON. YOU
KNOW SOMEONE STRUGGLING WITH
THIS BECAUSE I'VE SEEN THAT
ABUSE HERE OUT OF MY OWN CITY
HERE FOR JUST A FEW MILES FROM
HERE NOT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT BUT YOU KNOW VERY VERY.
WEALTHY INDIVIDUAL WITH PLENTY
OF TIME AND PLENTY OF MONEY ON
THEIR HANDS IT JUST TO SEE CRAP
ALL THE TIME ON HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT INEVITABLY- PAST SEVEN OR
BUILT IN JUST DELAYED AND COST
MONEY AND CREATED PROBLEMS. AND
I HEAR THE OPPOSITION FROM OUR
BUILDING TRADES AS WELL BUT HOW
WOULD YOU RSPOND MR GALLAGHER
TO YOU KNOW WHAT MR MARTUCCI NOT
MENTIONED WHAT IT YOU KNOW THIS
INDIVIDUAL HERE IS A WELL HEELED
YOU KNOW HAS A MULTI YOU KNOW
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR TRUST AND
CAN JUST THIS IS JUST FINE FOR
THEM. BUT WHAT IF THERE'S A
LEGITIMATE NEIGHBORHOOD GROUP
THAT DOESN'T HAVE RESOURCES IS
TALKING ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUES AND AIR QUALITY
AND SO FORTH THEY DON'T HAVE THE
WHERE WITH ALL POTENTIALLY A
LARGE ORGANIZATION. MISTER SMITH
REPRESENTS OR YOU KNOW THIS
MASSIVE TRUST YOUR ANY
SACRAMENTO THAT KELLY TRUST THAT
GOES OUT ALL THE TIME HOW WOULD
YOU RESPOND TO THEIR OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE IN. THE- ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESS VIA SEQUEL. WELL
I GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT
IF THERE'S A CASE LIKE THAT
WHERE YOU KNOW THEIR ADDRESS
SEEN LEGITIMATE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS FROM THE CASE I THINK
IT'S PROBABLY UNLIKELY THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A BOND
REQUIREMENT BECAUSE AGAIN THIS
IS MAY IT'S NOT SHALL REQUIRE A
BONDING REQUIREMENT FOR EVERY
CHALLENGE. TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- PROJECT- I THINK IT IS
TRYING TO GET OUT THAT LIMITED
AND AGAIN SOMEONE YOU HAVE TO
PETITION OR THE COURT WOULD HAVE
TO DO IT ON ITS OWN MOTION- ON
THE PART ABOUT THE COURT DOING
TIME MOTION IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING I'M WILLING TO TALK
ABOUT AND WHEN WE'LL BE TALKING
ABOUT- IF I MOVE ON TO MISTER
STONES COMMITTEE- AND SO- YOU
CAN DEFINITELY LOOK AT THAT
ISSUE- BUT- I DON'T SEE IT AS
BEING AN IMPEDIMENT LIKE IF YOU
HAVE A LEGITIMATE. SEQUEL
LAWSUIT YOU CAN STILL BRING IT.
AND YOU KNOW THERE MAY BE A
BONDING REQUIREMENT REQUIRED-
AGAIN THAT'S NOT USUALLY LIKE
PUTTING UP THE FULL AMOUNT OF
THE LAWSUIT IT'S A- NO PORTION
PERCENTAGE THERE OF SO I DON'T
SEE IT IS STOPPING ANY KIND OF
LEGITIMATE. SEQUEL LAWSUIT WHAT
IT WILL TRY AND DO IS DETER. THE
ONES THAT YOU KNOW AS YOU'VE
NOTICED IN YOUR OWN COMMUNITY
THAT ARE- YEP NOT MERITORIOUS
ARE REALLY JUST BEING BOUGHT
BROUGHT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
DELAY. I HEY MISTER SEYARTO SO
KIND OF IN RESPONSE TO A LITTLE
BIT WHAT I'VE BEEN HEARING- BUT
YEAH I'VE SEEN SEVERAL OF THESE
WHERE IT'S THE COMMUNITIES AND
AFTER ARE BECAUSE THERE IS A-
AND THE DEVELOPMENT THEY DON'T
LIKE GOING INTO WHETHER IT'S
AFFORDABLE HOW HOMES ARE HIGH
DENSITY HOMES OR WHATEVER AND
THEY NEVER SEEM TO BE- AT A LOSS
TO BE ABLE TO FIND AN ATTORNEY-
USUALLY THE ATTORNEY FINDS THEM.
AND AND SO THEY'RE NOT THE ONES
THAT ARE KIND OF AT RISK OF
DOING THE SUIT ESPECIALLY IF
THAT ATTORNEY IS CONFIDENT- THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO- PREVAIL IN A
IN A IN A SUIT THAT'S THAT'S
FINE BUT WHAT I'VE ALSO FOUND IS
THAT THESE ATTORNEYS- SOME OF
THEM- ENGAGE AND GET A SMALL.
YEAH BASICALLY A PALE. AND THEN
EVERYBODY YOU KNOW AND THE
PEOPLE THERE WERE NOT FOR AND
THEY DON'T HAVE TO PAY ANYTHING.
THEY JUST LA I MEAN THEY JUST
DID DEVELOPMENT GOES FORWARD
REGARDLESS OF THEIR CONCERNS.
AND YOU KNOW YOU GET TO MORE
STOP SIGNS PUT IN. AND THE
ATTORNEY GETS D. V- A
SETTLEMENT- FROM FROM THAT. AND
SO I DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS WILL BE
UNABLE TO ACCESS BECAUSE I THINK
THIS PLENTY PEOPLE REPRESENTING
THEM. THAT'LL DO IT WITHOUT-
WITHOUT THEM GETTING CHARGED- SO
I THINK WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO
HERE THE AUTHORS TRYING TO DO
HERE. IS NOBLE AND TRYING TO GET
ONE OF THE HURDLES OF OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- SITUATION-
KIND OF DEALT WITH. SO I THINK
IT'S A GOOD BILL AND- PLAN AND
SPORTING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
CASEY NINE I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
I KNOW YOU JUST- HEARD THEIR
CONCERNS RECENTLY- BUT I THINK
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
THROUGH IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE-
INCLUDING WITH THE CHAIR OF THE
NEXT COMMITTEE- LIKE HIS
COMMENTS TODAY SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING TODAY OF WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MATHIS AND A
SECOND. BY MISTER C. R. TO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- YES MA'AM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU AGAIN- AND
CERTAINLY I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION- MISTER
DONUT JUST SETS AND I THINK WAS
REALLY GOOD I JUST WANTED TO AND
WITH THIS IS THERE'S ALSO STATUS
QUO RIGHT NOW IS COSTING
NONPROFITS YOU KNOW LIKE HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
THEY CONTINUE TO LOSE MONEY
HAVING TO FEND THESE LAWSUITS
THE DELAY BECAUSE FROM THE-
THESE MUCH NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS THEY'RE LOSING
MONEY EVERY DAY. THIS JUST HELPS
KIND OF AT LEAST BRING SOME
BALANCE TO THAT SITUATION TO
HELP- WHERE THERE ARE WHERE
THERE ARE- YOU KNOW FRIVOLOUS
CASES BEING BROUGHT TO STOP
THESE PROJECTS SO I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND- THANK YOU
MEMBERS. BASED OKAY SECRETARY Q.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY JERRY
THIS HI RIVAS HI FLORA FLORA HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA MATHIS- MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY ARMORED TO
CHAI. CHEE I SAY ARE TOO HIGH
CITY ARE TO AYE STONE STONE I
WOULD. WHAT I. THE BILL HAS NINE
VOTES- WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VENTURE THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
MOVE TO ITEM SIX. AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY MR GRAYSON. WE WILL. YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO START TAKE
THAT WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU FOR PUTTING GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS AND MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AND I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
WHICH CREATES CONSUMER REBATE
PROGRAM FOR CONVERTING CARS ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS ARE SHIFTING TOWARD A
CLEANER FUTURE CONSUMERS AND THE
CAR INDUSTRY HAVE BEGUN
CONVERTING USED GASOLINE POWERED
VEHICLES. INTO HYDROGEN AND
ELECTRIC ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
MAJOR AUTOMAKERS INCLUDING FORD
AND GENERAL MOTORS HAVE UNVEILED
ZERO EMISSION CRATE MOTORS THEY
CAN BE USED TO REPLACE THE
ENGINE IN A GAS POWERED VEHICLE.
ONE MANUFACTURER OFFERS A
COMPLETE RETROFIT KIT FOR A
CLASSIC VOLKSWAGEN BEETLE AT
JUST UDER EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
THAT'S TEN THOUSAND CHEAPER THAN
SOME OF THE MOST INEXPENSIVE
ELECTRIC CARS ON THE MARKET SO
TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMERS
DEMAND. FOR MOREAFFORDABLE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS THE
STATE NEEDS NEW AND CREATIVE
WAYS TO MAKE ZAB OWNERSHIP MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE. BY
CREATING A CONSUMER REBATE
PROGRAM BY CONVERTING USE
GASOLINE POWER CARS INTO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE. AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY WILL HELP THE STATE
MEET ITS AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS. I AM GRATEFUL TO HAVE-
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BY PART. BUT
ON THIS BILL UP TO THIS POINT
AND I DO HAVE A WITNESS TO THE
CHAIR IT IS CHRISTIAN ROBINSON
WITH THE SPECIALTY EQUIPMENT
MARKET ASSOCIATION. OKAY
OPERATOR IF YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINE FOR MISTER ROBINSON.
MISTER ROBINSON CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. NIGHT YET JERRY VETS LESTER
FLORIDA MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY SIX CREATING
A PROGRAM TO INCENTIVIZE
CONSUMERS TO CONVERT GASOLINE OR
DIESEL POWERED VEHICLES AND TO
THOSE THAT ARE ZERO EMISSION- MY
NAME IS CHRISTIAN ROBINSON. ON
BEHALF OF THE SPECIALTY
EQUIPMENT MARKET ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS HEADQUARTERED IN
DIAMOND BAR CALIFORNIA. TEAM AT
THE TRADE ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS. MORE THAN SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED MOSTLY SMALL
BUSINESSES NATIONWIDE INCLUDING
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED IN THE
GOLDEN STATE. THAT MANY.
SOUTHWEST ABOUT ABOUT ABOUT FROM
PRODUCTS. IT'S FOR RESTORATION
TECHNOLOGY PRODUCTS FOR CARS AND
TRUCKS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
NOTED THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT AMBITIOUS GOALS FOR
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY IN THE
MOVING VEHICLES FROM THE ROAD.
AIMING TO HAVE ALL NEW CAR SALES
VVV BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE CURRENT
MARKET PLACE YOU THE EITHER OUT
OF REACH FOR MOST CONSUMERS.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT
FROM BLOOMBERG ONLY 15% OF
DRIVERS CAN AFFORD A NEW THE
EEVEE. CONSIDERING THE FACTORS
TOGETHER TWO THINGS ARE CLEAR
CONSUMERS NEED MORE OPTIONS WHEN
CONSIDERING THE PURCHASE OF THE
E. THREE AND THE NEED FOR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. HAPPEN AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY TACKLES BOTH
AT THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE FEMA
SHOW ABOUT THE GETS WHICH WITH
THE LARGEST AUTOMOTIVE TRADE
SHOW IN NORTH AMERICA SINCE THE
PANDEMIC LEVY CONVERSION STOLE
THE SHOW INCLUDING VEHICLES
POWERED BY CHEN ET CRATE. FOR
THE LAMINATOR ELECTRIC MOTORS
SHOULD BE CHEVY THE CRATE
INCLUDES AN ELECTRIC MOTOR
BATTERY SYSTEM IN TRANSMISSION
IT CAN BE INSTALLED ON ANYBODY
TO BE A CALL. FOR PORTLAND MAJOR
COSTS JUST UNDER FOUR THOUSAND.
IN ITS INITIAL PRODUCTION RUN
SOLD OUT VERY QUICKLY. CAN YOU
WORDING THE CARD. ON THE EVE V.
IF YOU ABOUT IT LIKE THE FOR
CONSUMER CALIFORNIANS ARE
CRITICAL WHILE THE MEDIAN INCOME
EMISSION. OVER THERE NO CURRENT
SUPPORTED BURKE TO INTO
CONVERTING TO BE TO POWER CARS
AND RUN ON HYDROGEN ARE LOCKED.
TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S DEMAND FROM
WORK TO CREATE. OPTION THE STATE
. NEEDS NEW CREATIVE WAYS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SET ACCOMPLISH
THESE GOALS MAKE THAT EASY
VIEWER MARC THE PATH OF AB
TWENTY THIRTY WHICH I TWENTY
THREE FIFTY HOW COMPLICATED FOR
THE TREATMENT THE MASTERS. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TO BE
HAPPENING ATTORNEYS ALL THE
QUESTIONS. SHE'S YEAH IS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. I'M SORRY THERE IS ONLY
ONE ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM ANYBODY IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
PERFECT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. SO
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION. FOUR COMMENT IN
THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEN NONE SURVEYS WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU I'M CERTAINLY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR RIVAS.
FLORA BY FLORA AYE
BOERNER HORVATH. HI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA MATHIS- MATHIS AND
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI RICHIE I SAY ARE TO
SAY ARE SO AYE STONE STONE I
WOULD. WOOD HI. THE BILL AS A
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MYSTERY THIS. PRESENT IN AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN. THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR COLLEAGUES GREAT
TO SEE EVERYBODY THIS AFTERNOON
AND AT THAT BEFORE I BEGIN I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE WORK ON THIS
LEGISLATION AND LIKE TO KNOW
THAT ARE WEEKS EXCEPT IN THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- AND THIS
LEGISLATION IS ON THE BILL TO
SIX ONE THREE SEEKS TO CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
EXISTING FARM AND RANCH SOLID
WASTE CLEANUP AND ABATEMENT
GRANT PROGRAM. TO HELP FARMERS
AND RANCHERS ACCESS FUNDING TO
CLEAN UP ILLEGAL DUMPING ON THE
PROPERTIES ILLEGAL DUMPING OF
TRASH ON FARMLANDS THREATENS
FOOD SAFETY- CAN CAUSE CROP LOSS
AS WELL AS LOSS OF CERTIFICATION
FOR ORGANIC FARMERS. AND WHILE
THE EXISTING GRANT PROGRAM WAS
INTENDED TO HELP FARMERS AND
RANCHERS CLEAN UP ILLEGALLY
DUMPED TRASH ON THE PROPERTIES
OVER TIME MORE AND MORE OF THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM HAS
GONE TO LANDS THAT ARE NOT IN
ACTIVE AGRICULTURAL USE. AS A
RESULT FARMERS AND RANCHERS ARE-
THEY'RE GETTING LESS AND LESS
FUNDING FROM A PROGRAM THAT IS
CURRENTLY OVER SUBSCRIBED- EVEN
THOUGH ILLEGAL DUMPING ON THEIR
LANDS IS INCREASING- THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT AS ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
BECOME AVAILABLE FUNDS ARE
DEDICATED TO FARMERS AND
RANCHERS AS PART OF THE OF THIS
NEW- THE PILOT PROGRAM I WITH
MEAT HERE TO TESTIFIES OF THESE
KÞT LITTLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BASED
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS KATIE
LITTLE AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU. FARM BUREAU IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTEEN TODAY WHICH WOULD
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR FARMERS
AND RANCHERS TO CLEAN UP
ILLEGALLY DUMPED WASTE ON THE
PROPERTY. FARMS REPRESENTS MORE
THAN THIRTY TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS
STRIVES TO PROTECT AND IMPROVE
THE BAY AVAILABILITY OF FOR
FARMERS AND RANCHERS ENGAGED
PRODUCTION AGRICULTURE. AND
PROJECT SAFE RELIABLE FOOD FOR
THE CONSUMERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. CURRENTLY CAL RECYCLE
ADMINISTERS OF FARM AND RANCH
SOLID WASTE ABATEMENT CLEANUP
PROGRAM WITH THIS SIMILAR GOAL
TO THE PILOT ARE PROPOSING
TODAY. THIS PROGRAM IS FUNDED
ANNUALLY AT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO VARIOUS WAYS FUNDS. THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES GRANTS TO
PUBLIC ENTITIES A CITY COUNTY
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
ARE RECOGNIZED NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBE FOR CLEAN UP AND ABATEMENT
OF PROJECTS. ON BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE LANDS IN THE PAST MANY
OF THESE AWARDS HAVE BEEN
GRANTED TOWARDS PUBLIC CLEANUP.
THAT WAS ZONED FOR AGRICULTURE
BUT WOULD NOT AND ACTIVE
AGRICULTURAL USE WITH THE RECENT
INCREASE OF ILLEGAL DUMPING
POSSIBLY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
RECENT COVED NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THIS FUND HAS BECOME
OVERSUBSCRIBED. AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTEEN HOPES TO. HELP
RESEARCHERS WITH THIS BY
PRIORITIZING THE ACTIVE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY CLEAN UP
ON FARMING AND RANCHING
OPERATIONS. SINCE THE CURRENT
PROGRAM ALLOWS FOR PUBLIC
ENTITIES TO ALSO APPLY FOR THE
FUNDS FARMERS AND RANCHERS MUST
COMPETE FOR FUNDING IN AN
OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAM. THE
CURRENT PROCESSES ULTIMATELY
STRETCHED ACROSS MANY APPLICANTS
IN ADDITION TO FARMERS AND
RANCHERS BY PRIORITIES IN FORT
FARMERS AND RANCHERS THIS PILOT
GUARANTEES FUNDING WILL GO
DIRECTLY TO CLEANING UP. FARMS
AND RANCHERS IN ENSURING FOOD
SAFETY FOR THE CONSUMER.
FURTHERMORE IT WOULD SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S CLEAN UP CALIFORNIA
SHIP THAT WAS RELEASED LAST
YEAR. THIS IS JUST ONE OF THE
MANY OBSTACLES THAT FACE FARMERS
AND RANCHERS THIS YEAR ALONG
WITH THE DROUGHT SUPPLY. ISSUES
INFLATION AND INCREASING
REGULATORY. PRESSURES FARMERS
MUST ALL SO FIGHT AGAINST OF THE
LEAGUE ACTIVE. THAT THREATEN
THEIR LIVELIHOODS. THIS PILOT
HOPES TO HELP FARMERS AND
RANCHERS KEEP CALM AT LEAST ONE
OF THESE OBSTACLES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT. SEEN THEM IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM REMOVED
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO- STATED
OPPOSITION. ANY OPPOSITION THE
PHONE LINES. OR COMMENTS
RELATING TO AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
EURO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO
. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM
LINE TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JASON BRYANT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MR MISTRUTHS I APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS ON THIS. I'VE BEEN
WORKING IN THIS SPACE TRYING TO
HELP- DUMPING ON EGGLAND'S FOR
QUITE SOME TIME I'D LOVE TO BE A
JOINT AUTHORS ON THIS TO SHOW
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE SEEING NONE.
SHARIA'S WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECT THAT'S PRIVATE I THINK
THEY'RE MUCH BETTER GROUP LEGAL. THE MOTION TO MOVE WITH A
GLASS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. RIVAS
FLOOR BY FLOOR AYE
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I FRIEDMAN. GARCIA MATHIS-
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I SEE YOUR
TO SAY ARE TO AYE STONE. STONE I
WOULD. WOOD I. THERE WAS A BILL
AS A THOSE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR OTHER MEMBERS. BUT ALRIGHT
MR CORK. AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
CAN MEMBERS. BOB FIRST I WANT TO
THANK COMMITTEE STAFFER
FANTASTIC ANALYSIS. AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY SEVEN PHASES OUT THE
USE OF ONLINE TIPS FOR PRODUCED
WATER DISPOSAL. WHEN OIL IS
PRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
EIGHTEEN BARRELS OF PRODUCED
WATER GENERATED WITH EVERY
BARREL OF OIL. THIS PRODUCED
WATER CAN SOMETIMES BE USED. IN
AGRICULTURE AND FOR OTHER
PURPOSES BUT MANY TIMES IT
CONTAINS HIGH LEVEL OF SALTS
FLUORIDE. ARSENIC AND OTHER
CHEMICALS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION. BOB WHEN
PRODUCED WATERS DISPOSED OF IT
ONLINE. CHEMICALS FROM THE WASTE
WATER OR RELIGION RELEASED
DIRECTLY INTO THE ENVIRONMENT.
VOLATILE CHEMICALS LIKE BENZENE
EVAPORATE INTO THE AIR. WELL
WATER SALTS AND OTHER CHEMICALS
PARTICULATE INTO THE SOIL AND
GROUNDWATER BELOW. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN A REPORT BY THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY. A LARGE BERKELEY
NATIONAL LAB RAISED ABOUT THIS
PRACTICE. REPORTS AUTHORS
RECOMMENDED THAT THE STATE
ENSURE SAFE DISPOSAL OF PRODUCED
WATER IN PARTICULAR SHOULD PET
WITH APPROPRIATE TESTING AND
TREATMENT OR PHASE OUT THIS
PRACTICE. SINCE ITS
RECOMMENDATION STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT PRODUCED WATER
DISPOSAL IT ONLINE IT IS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED GROUNDWATER
THE COULD BE USED FOR IRRIGATION
OR OTHER BENEFICIAL USES.
GROUNDWATER'S CRITICAL FOR
IRRIGATION DURING DROUGHTS IN
THE CONTINUED USE OF ONLINE
PITCH FOR PRODUCED WATE
DISPOSAL POSES A RISK TO
PRECIOUS GROUNDWATER RESOURCES.
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY MAJOR OIL
AND GAS PRODUCING STATE THAT
STILL ALLOWS ONLINE TICKETS FOR
WASTEWATER DISPOSAL. THIS BILL
FOLLOWS THE LEAD OF OTHER STATES
INCLUDING POLLUTING TEXAS NEW
MEXICO AND NORTH DAKOTA. AND
PHASES OUT ONLINE PITCH STARTING
IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WITH ME
TODAY IS DR DOMINIC. D. JULIA.
THAT'S DR DOMINIC TO JULIA-
FROM- HEALTHY ENERGY AND HAY
SEUSS ALONSO FROM CLEAN WATER
ACTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ITS FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. I THINK THAT ON THE GOOD
AFTERNOON AND KICKING. WHAT THE
HECK. FIRST WITH US IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT MY SUPPORT FOR A P.
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN MY
NAME'S HAS WAS ALONE SO ON THE
CURRENT CAMINO ORGANIZER FOR
CLEAN WATER ACTION. WASTEWATER
UNLINED PITS A SCENE IN THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO FIFTY STUDY
HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON OUR
AIR AND GROUND WATER QUALITY.
CONTAMINATION FROM GROUND WATER
THAT IS BEING USED BY A
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITY IS A
VIOLATION OF THEIR HUMAN RIGHT
TO WATER. I THINK COMMUNITIES
ARE PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. YOU DO NOT
HAVE THE LUXURY OF JUST MOVING
TO A BETTER PLACE- THEY WOULD%
NEED TO STAY AND HAVE THEIR
FAMILIES PERPETUALLY EXPOSED TO
AN UNDISCLOSED NUMBER OF
CONTAMINANTS AND TOXINS. AND IT
WOULD BE IN CONSTANT RISK OF
DEVELOPING CANCER AND ANY NUMBER
OF CARDIOVASCULAR AND
NEUROLOGICAL HEALTH ISSUES- WE
KNOW THAT LIVING YOUR POLLUTION
SOURCES IS HARMFUL FOR ONE'S
HEALTH. AND ALLOWING A NINE
PITCH CONTINUE AS THEYARE WOULD
BE RISKING. BRINGING THOSE VERY
SAME CONTAMINANTS DIRECTLY INTO
THE HOME. THERE'S REALLY NO MORE
OR LOGICAL REASON FOR WHY THE
STATE SHOULD REMAIN ONLINE. THE
NEED OF THE INDUSTRY TO SAVE A
FEW BUCKS DOES NOT OUTWEIGH THE
RISK THEY POSE TO OUR FAMILIES.
ABOUT THE DEADLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
IN SUPPORT PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER SARAH MY NAME
IS TOM JULIA. HE I AM A SENIOR
RESEARCH SCIENTIST AT PC
HEALTHCARE G. AND A RESEARCH
AFFILIATE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
COLORADO I WAS PREVIOUSLY
EMPLOYED BY THE U. S. HE'D BE A
FOR THIRTY ONE YEARS AS A
REGULATOR. HE GOT AS A RESEARCH
SCIENTIST I WAS THE LEAD AUTHOR
OF A PAPER. RECENTLY PUBLISHED
IN ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY OUTLINING THE PAST.
AND CURRENT PRACTICE OF DISPOSAL
PRODUCED WATER INTO ONLINE
PRODUCE WATER BOND IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ITS IMPACT ON
GROUNDWATER RESOURCES. IT IS
WELL KNOWN TO NUMEROUS PUBLISHED
STUDIES. AT THIS DISPOSAL
PRACTICE BECAUSE THIS DROUGHT OR
CONTAMINATION. FOR THIS REASON
TO MY KNOWLEDGE THE EVERY STATE
EXCEPT CALIFORNIA HAS BANNED
THIS PRACTICE. FOR THIS PRACTICE
OF TAPERED OFF IN RECENT YEARS
THE VOLUME OF PRODUCED WATER
DISPOSAL AN ONLINE PART IN
CALIFORNIA STILL LARGE AND IS
COMPATIBLE TO THE TOTAL VOLUME
OF PRODUCE BORDER IN OTHER OIL
AND GAS PRODUCING STATES SUCH AS
PENNSYLVANIA. OUR MONITORING IS
SPARSE BUT WHERE IT HAS OCCURRED
IMPACT REGIONAL THE AQUIFERS AND
GROUNDWATER HAVING BENEFICIAL
USE. HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED. ONCE
GROUND WATER IS CONTAMINATED BY
SELLING WATER IT CANNOT BE
CLEANED UP. IT CAN ONLY BE
DISPERSED OVER TENS OR HUNDREDS
. FIVE YEARS. THIS PRACTICE HAS
AND CONTINUES TO CAUSE MAJOR
NATURAL RESOURCE DAMAGE. OVER
SIXTEEN BILLION BARRELS OF
SELLING WATER HAVE BEEN DISPOSED
. AN ONLINE COUPONS HE OVER THE
PAST FORTY FIVE YEARS CREATING A
MASSIVE GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATION PROBLEM FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. OUR IS NOT STAGNANT
LARGE GROUNDWATER PLUMES WILL
MOVE THE OVERTIME AND EVENTUALLY
IMPACT AGRICULTURAL AND PUBLIC
SUPPLY WELLS. FOR THESE REASONS
I AT THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
BECAUSE HE GAVE ME TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE GOT ONE
WITH US IN OPPOSITION MISTER
CALDERON. COME ON UP. TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THAT
DOWNSIDE WHEREVER YOU'RE MORE
COMFORTABLE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PAUL THE EURO REPRESENTING THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION- WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWO FOUR FOUR SEVEN
WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT THE
PLACEMENT OF PRODUCED WATER AND
BUYING PONDS. SIX THIS ACTIVITY
IS HIGHLY REGULATED BY THE
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY BOARD
WHICH INCLUDES THREE LEVELS OF
REGULATION THAT REFLECT THE
RELATIVELY THE RELATIVE RISK TO
GROUNDWATER FROM OILFIELD THAT
PRODUCED WATERS. IF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING. IT RELATED TO WHAT
THE PROPONENTS WERE SAYING AS
FAR AS GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATION- AIR QUALITY
ISSUES. SPONSORED BE SHUT DOWN.
THESE THESE REGARD HIGHLY
REGULATED- AT AT AT AT EVERY
TURN- IF THE GROUND IF THERE IS
GROUNDWATER THE REGIONAL WATER
QUALITY BOARD DOES A ROBUST RISK
ASSESSMENT AND MAKES A
DETERMINATION IF A PERMIT IS
WARRANTED. MONITORING IS
CONDUCTED BY THE REGIONAL BOARD
REGULATING ENFORCING IN THE HEAD
THE USE OF PRODUCED WATER PONDS.
IF THE IF THE COMMONLY GO OUT
AND MONITOR THESE POINTS TO MAKE
SURE THEY ARE SAFE AND THERE IS
NO MIGRATION OCCURRING IF BY
GRATION WAS OCCURRING THESE
BONDS WOULD BE SHUT DOWN. OVER
THE COURSE OF- THE LAST COUPLE
OF DECADES TO THE RIVER THERE
BUT SOME OPERATORS HAVE PHASED
OUT THE USE BUT IT'S CRITICAL TO
OUR OPERATORS AND SOME OF THE
SMALLER OPERATORS. THAT THEY
ALLOW THESE ONLINE PAWNS. OR
WHERE THE BUSINESSES WHAT WILL
GO OUT OF BUSINESS- I DO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING SOME
AMENDMENTS AS IT RELATES TO
BENEFICIAL USE. S. SPECIFIC TO
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE AND- WATER
TO AG. IT'S ONLY FOR EXISTING
PROJECTS NOT FOR FUTURE PROJECTS
OF WHICH MOST OF THE PRODUCERS
ARE LOOKING AT NOW- SO AGAIN IF
ALL OF THIS WERE OCCURRING. D.
THE REGIONAL- QUALITY WATER
BOARD WHICH AT THESE BONDS DOWN
IMMEDIATELY- FOR THOSE REASONS
WE WE'RE WE REMAIN OPPOSED AND
WILL CONTINUE TO OPPOSE BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OFFICE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE-
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- SEAN ONE TIME
FROM THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT ALL THE PONDS
THAT THIS BILL IMPACTS ARE IN
KERN COUNTY- THERE NOWHERE ELSE-
EVERY PRODUCED WATER POND AS THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS- POINTED OUT IS
UNDER THE WATCHFUL EYE OF THE
WATER BOARD. THEY'RE ALL
REGULATED MONITORED AND
PERMITTED. AND AS WAS STATED THE
WATER BOARD HAS FULL AUTHORITY
TO SHUT DOWN ANY POND THAT IS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING DRINKING
WATER GROUNDWATER. THEY ALREADY
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY- THIS BILL-
WHICH SHUT DOWN UP TO THREE
MILLION BARRELS OF ANNUAL
PRODUCTION IN KERN COUNTY- KERN
COUNTY OIL WORKERS WOULD LOSE
THEIR JOBS IN THE COUNTY AND
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES. WOULD LOSE
CRITICAL TAXES NEEDED TO FUND
VITAL PUBLIC SERVICES WORSE
CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE TO REPLACE
THIS LOST KERN OIL WITH OIL FROM
PLACES LIKE ECUADOR'S AMAZON
RAINFOREST. MANY OF THE PONDS IN
KERN COUNTY ARE FOR BENEFICIAL
REUSE IN AGRICULTURE BUT MANY
ARE NOT DUE TO THEIR HIGH
SALINITY AND I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT. SEVEN MEMBERS HAVE FOR
YEARS BEEN 1100% COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES ON CV SALTS WHICH IS
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SALINITY
ALTERNATIVES- FOR LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS AND THE WATER BOARD'S
REQUIRED BASIN PLAN AND BASIN
PLAN AMENDMENT PROCESS. WHICH
CONTAINS THREE SPECIFIC POND
ORDERS THAT DEAL DIRECTLY WITH
PRODUCED WATER PONDS. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO NOTE THE CALIFORNIA IT
IS CLEARLY- IN A PERPETUAL
DROUGHT IN THE OIL INDUSTRY IS A
KEY PARTNER WITH AGRICULTURE
FARMERS HAVE DESCRIBED PRODUCED
WATER FROM OIL PRODUCTION. AS A
LIFELINE DURING TIMES OF
DROUGHT- THE OIL INDUSTRY
PROVIDES CRITICAL WATER NEEDED
FOR THE IRRIGATION OF CROPS AND-
CONTRARY TO WHAT IS STATED
SOMETIMES IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN.
OIL PRODUCERS- WE ARE A NET
PRODUCER OF BENEFICIAL- USE
WATER UP TO THE AMOUNT OF ABOUT
FORTY THREE THOUSAND ACRE FEET
PER YEAR- THIS BILL IS NOT ONLY
UNNECESSARY BUT IT WOULD. CAUSE
HARM SUPPORT SUPER RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE GO BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OR OPPOSITION. ON THE
PHONE LINES. FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION A. B. TWO
FOUR FOUR SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO SPEND ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
START WITH LINE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JENNIFER CLARY THE
COMPANY DIRECTOR FOR CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND I'M I'M SPEAKING AT
THE PORT OF THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF OUR ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY THE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER BUT CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NETWORK THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY TWO.
KLEIN THIRTY TWO HEREBY COULD
OPEN. THIS IS SANTIAGO WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTING
IN SUPPORT OF. IN A LINE OF
THIRTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. A LINE
OF. FIFTEEN I DID HE SAID
CORDOBA WITH THE N. B. NATURAL
RESOURCES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AND THE- LINE.
THIRTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON KIM
DELFINO- REPRESENTING DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. BLIND THIRTY THREE. HELLO
THIS IS BILL ELLIOTT WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP IT
WAS MY WORK ALONG WITH A
COLLEAGUE FROM CLEAN WATER
ACTION THAT BROUGHT THIS ISSUE
TO THE REGIONAL WATER BOARD
ATTENTION I WOULD NOT CALL IT
OVER REGULATED NOW THEY'RE STILL
CATCHING UP WITH ALL THE PONDS
ABOUT A THIRD OF WHICH HAD NO
PERMITS ARE ALSO A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO. IN THE AG ISSUE IS
NOT A FACTOR HERE THE BILL TAKE
CARE OF THAT BENEFICIAL USE.
THANK YOU. IN A LINE OF THIRTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ELENA
ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION
FUND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN
LINE TWENTY SIX. GEN MOURNED
BONTA CREEK IN SUPPORT. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO
MISTER FLORA FOR TAKING OVER
WHILE I WAS VOTING IN REVENUE
TAX- ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. MR FLOOR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I THINK
IT AFTER CORPORATE BRING THIS
FORWARD YOU'RE ALWAYS OF THE
VERY THOUGHTFUL- COLLEAGUES I
APPRECIATE THAT I DO HAVE JUST A
COUPLE CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IN. AND LARGEST
COME FROM A CENTRAL VALLEY
PERSPECTIVE- THE CONCERNS AT
THIS BILL CAN REALLY REDUCE THE
SUPPLY OF TWO THINGS THAT ARE
VITAL. TO OUR WAY OF LIFE IT'S
WATER AND QUITE FRANKLY FUEL AND
OF WHERE YOU ARE RIGHT NOW-
MINUTE DROP SO ANYTHING THAT IS
DONE TO LESSEN. THE POTENTIAL
WATER SUPPLY I HAVE STRONG
CONCERNS ABOUT AS WELL AS WE
HAVE SIX DOLLARS OUR FUEL SIX
DOLLARS A GALLON FUEL NOT AN
HOUR. BUT SIX DOLLARS GALLON
FUEL. YAHOO KIDDING THE CUTTING
YOU KNOW COUPLE HUNDRED THOUSAND
BARRELS OF THE FUEL OUT OF THE
SYSTEM I THINK COULD BE
DEVASTATING AND IN THE WORLD WE
LIVE IN RIGHT NOW I THINK THAT'S
A LITTLE BUT THE WRONG APPROACH
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
RIGHT NOW THERE'S A LOT OF
FEASIBILITY STUDIES AT THE STATE
WATER BOARD THE LOCAL WATER
DISTRICTS ARE DOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS WATER CAN BE RECLAIMED
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO TAKE
A PAUSE. AND LET THEM DO IT
JOBS- BECAUSE IF WE CAN RECLAIM
WATER WASTE WATER FROM OUR
CITIES AND REVIEWS THAT I FEEL
LIKE WE CAN GET THE TECHNOLOGY
RIGHT REVIEWS SOME OF THIS WATER
FOR OTHER ISSUES OTHER THAN JUST
AGRICULTURE SO THANK YOU. YES
SO. AS THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
WHICH VÀ SAID. IT'S NOT OUR
INTENTION AND THAT BELIEVE THE
BILL AS CURRENTLY BEING AMENDED
WELL ABSOLUTELY NOT TOUCH
BENEFICIAL REUSE THE PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORTED THE PEOPLE WHO OPPOSE
IT THIS BILL WILL BE COMPLETELY
NEUTRAL ON THAT. AND WE WILL NOT
SO FAR AS I CAN SEE CHANGE ONE
DROP. FROM BENEFICIAL RE USE
THAT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE
ABSOLUTELY. SO WHAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT HERE IS THE FACT
THAT THE WATER BOARD REALLY
DOESN'T REGULATE THESE POTS IN
AN EFFECTIVE WAY- AND ALTHOUGH
THE CENTRAL VALLEY REGIONAL
BOARD HAS DONE A LOT OF HARD
WORK ON THIS ISSUE. THE CURRENT
REGULATIONS ROUND ONLINE PICTURE
EXTREMELY CUMBERSOME FOR ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED OF THEM. WERE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS TO GROUNDWATER
QUALITY DETECTED THE REGIONAL
BOARD MUST METICULOUSLY DOCUMENT
THE IMPACT. AND ISSUE SHE SHOULD
DESIST ORDERS. IT BY. WITH FIVE
HUNDRED PIPS. YOU'RE NEVER GOING
TO GET TO THE END OF THIS.
REGIONAL BOARD IS ACTED TO SHUT
DOWN SOME TIPS BUT THEY HAVE TO
ADDRESS EACH SITUATION
INDIVIDUALLY. AND THE PROCEEDS
CAN BE DRAGGED OUT BY LITIGATION
. SO THE STAFF TIME AND
RESOURCES BEING SPENT BASICALLY
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO LOOK AT
ALL FIVE HUNDRED OF THESE
THEY'VE GOT A LOOK AT THEM ONE
BY ONE- IF A- IF THE OPPOSITION
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT A MORE
EFFECTIVE REGULATING REGIME WE
COULD TALK ABOUT THAT. OF BUT
RIGHT NOW WE DO SEE THE IMPACT
OF THIS ON WHAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE USABLE GROUNDWATER SO WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THIS APPROACH IF
THE OPPOSITION WANTS TO GET HELP
TAKE ANOTHER APPROACH BUT THE
CURRENT APPROACH ISN'T WORKING
AT ALL AND I'D BE GLAD TO TALK
WITH THE OPPOSITION ABOUT IT SO
THANK YOU AND- ALWAYS FOR IS
THE- OKAY SO THE AMOUNT OF. OIL
WERE TALKING ABOUT IS 1% OF
CURRENT PRODUCTION PRODUCTION.
THE OTHER 9899% OF THE WELLS
FREE INJECT THE WATER
UNDERGROUND. AND THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD EXPECT TO HAPPEN IF THIS
BILL PASSES THAT INSTEAD OF
PUTTING IT ONLINE PETS WORK
CONTAMINATE THE WATER. IN THE
AIR. ARE THAT IT WOULD BE RE
INJECTED UNDERGROUND WHICH IS
WHAT WE GET 98299% OF THE
PRODUCTION. ALREADY DIED SO
WE'RE JUST ASKING THEM TO DO
WHAT THE OTHER PEOPLE DO
ALREADY. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR QUESTION AS ALWAYS-
IT'S VERY MUCH APPRECIATED. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SCENE NINE- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY- WE HAVE TO WE HAVE A
MOTION. HELLO OKAY THE MOTION BY
. MISTER SEA A SECOND BY MR
MCCARTY- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS THE BEST
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR RIVAS HI
RIVAS HI FLORA NO FLOOR NO
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS MATHIS
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY ANYWHERE TWO
G. THREE G. A. C. R. TO SEE HER
SO NO STONE. STONE AYE. WOOD I.
OKAY THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
CHAIR SURE. NEXT I SEE MISTER
CALDERON IN THE ROOM SO WE'LL GO
TO ITEM TWO AB. TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY SIX. THE PROPOSAL. GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF- FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE AND I'LL BE TAKING ALL
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS AB TWO FIVE SIX SIX
WILL CREATE A GRANT PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL
GREEN EFFORTS PARTICULARLY FOR
SCHOOLS LOCATED IN
DISADVANTAGED- LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING ESCALATING
INCONSISTENT EXTREME HEAT DAYS
DUE TO CLIMATE CHANGE CHILDREN
WHO ATTEND URBAN SCHOOLS WITH
LITTLE TO NO TREE CANOPIES ART
AN INCREASED RISK FOR HEAT
RELATED ILLNESSES LIKE SKIN
CANCER AND ASTHMA. BY CONVERTING
PAVED AREAS INTO GREENER SPACES
THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP
MEDIATE HIGH TEMPERATURES AND
IMPROVE THE OVERALL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF STUDENTS HERE WITH
ME TODAY SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FIVE SIX SIX IS ALFREDO-
DANDO ON BEHALF OF THE
TREEPEOPLE AND SASHA HOROWITZ
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF THE- LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. OKAY THANKS FOR
THE MISTRUST ON THE- I GET
AFTERNOON CHERRY THIS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS AND FEDERAL ON THE AND I'M
PROVIDING COMMENTS TO SUPPORT AB
TWO FIVE SIX SIX ON BEHALF OF
TREEPEOPLE SPONSORS OF THE OF
THE MEASURE. THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE INTRODUCED BY SOMEONE
WERE CALDERON AS PART OF A
LARGER LEGISLATIVE EFFORT TO
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS EXTREME
HEAT THROUGH A MULTITUDE OF
COOLING SOLUTIONS THAT PROTECT
FARMWORKERS HOMEOWNERS AND THE
MOST UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE THREE PEOPLE AS THE
LARGEST ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT
BASED IN LOS ANGELES UNITS WITH
COMMUNITIES TO GROW GREENER MORE
RESILIENT HOMES NEIGHBORHOODS
AND SCHOOLS. ALL THROUGH THE
LENS OF NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
THAT REINFORCE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE A
MYRIAD OF SCIENTIFIC STUDIES
THAT DEMONSTRATE HOW CLIMATE
CHANGE IS ALREADY EXACERBATING
THE NUMBER OF EXTREME HEAT DAYS
IN CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT SAID
TRIPLE HAS A STRONG INTEREST
YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH L. U. S.
T. FOR EXAMPLE IN CONDUCTING
READING PROJECTS AT SCHOOLS IN
PROVIDING ACADEMIC CONTENT TIED
TO OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION AND NATURAL RESOURCES
. WE KNOW THE VALUE OF THESE
INVESTMENTS FOR STUDENTS THAT
ONLY THE PHYSICAL BETTERMENT OF
THEIR ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO IN
FOSTERING BETTER ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES AS WELL. HOWEVER
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN VERY PIECEMEAL AND
LACK A CLEAR FOCUS ON SCHOOL
SITES. AB TWO FIVE SIX SIX
REMEDIES THIS BY LEVERAGING
THEIR EXISTING URBAN AND
COMMUNITY FORESTRY PROGRAM. AND
THE URBAN GREENING PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE GRANTS FOR SCHOOL
GREENING IN A UNIFIED MANNER
THAT. TAKES IN THE BEST OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND ALSO CENTERS OF THE
ROLE OF- THE ROLE THAT LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES NEED TO PLAY
IN THESE PROJECTS MOVING FORWARD
AS WELL. WELL NOT MENTION THE
CURRENT ALSO SO I WANTED TO END
BY SAYING THAT. AB TWO TWO FIVE
SIX SIX IS SUPPORTED BY OVER
FORTY PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE EDUCATION. AND RESOURCE
CONSERVATION SECTOR. I THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME SPEAK RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST NAY BUT- THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON TERRY
BISSON MEMBERS SOCIAL WORK WITH
WITH THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SIX HER
WE DID NOT HAVE A LETTER
PREPARED IN TIME FOR THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. ALL STUDENTS
DESERVE ACCESS TO OUTDOOR
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES AND A
SUSTAINABLE AND HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT. THIS PREVENTS NOT
ONLY HELP MITIGATE THE EFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE BUT THEY TEACH
STUDENTS ABOUT OUTDOOR LITERACY
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP. AND
OUR PLACE IN NATURE. AS THE
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
STATE AND THE SECOND LARGEST IN
THE COUNTRY LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
HAS MADE EXPANDING OUTDOOR
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS AND CREATING GREEN
SPACES KEY PRIORITIES FOR THE
DISTRICT. LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SERVES A POPULATION OF NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
80% OF WHOM QUALIFIED FOR FREE
AND REDUCED PRICE LUNCH AND MANY
OF WHOM LIVE IN AREAS OF HIGH
PARKING. THIS BILL WILL ENABLE
NOT ONLY LOS ANGELES UNIFIED BUT
HUNDREDS OF OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOL SITES
ACROSS THE STATE TO ACCESS THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED. TO GREEN
THEIR CAMPUSES IN AREAS WITH THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. THE DIVERSE PROJECTS
FUNDED UNDER THIS PROPOSAL WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO REDUCING THE HEAT
ISLAND EFFECT IN IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITIES. PROJECTS LIKE
BUILDING COMMUNITY GARDENS
OPENING CAMPUS AND COMMUNITY
PARKS PLANTING TREES CAPTURING
STORM WATER AND INSTALLING
REFLECTIVE SURFACES. WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
BALANCES THE GOALS OF REDUCING
AMBIENT HEAT WITH THE PRACTICAL
CONCERNS OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WHOSE CAMPUSES WILL BE IMPROVED
BY THESE GREENING PROJECTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON AND
HERS. STAFF HAVE BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE TO THE OBSTACLES THE
DISTRICTS LIKE OURS TO FACE IN
TRYING TO MAKE THESE PROJECTS
WORKED IN THE PAST. SINCE THESE
PROJECTS ARE CAMPUS BASED WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
ANY GRANT RECIPIENT MUST HAVE A
FORMAL AGREEMENT WITH THE SCHOOL
WHERE THE IMPROVEMENTS WILL TAKE
PLACE BEFORE APPLYING FOR THE
GRANT. THIS ONE SURE THE
PROJECTS ARE FEASIBLE
APPROPRIATELY SCOPED AND HAVE
BUY IN FROM THE DISTRICT WHILE
ALSO FACILITATING GENUINE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT BUILD ON THE
EXPERTISE OF LOCAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES. THANK YOU AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
PRIVATE. THANK YOU. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESSES REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN IT UP TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION STARTING IN THE
HEARING ROOM. HE'S SEEN NONE
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY SIX.OR COMMON IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
A ONE AND ZERO. WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE TWENTY SIX. BY
TWENTY. YEAH OKAY THANK YOU.
ALREADY I STAND WITH THOSE THAT
USE THE I AM SUPPORTIVE OF AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SIX THE HEAT
THE EXTREMES THAT ARE COMING ARE
REAL THANK YOU. CAN ONE EVER.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI MY
NAME IS CHUCK MILLS I'M WITH
THREE PEOPLE AND THE IN ADVANCE
A CONSULTATION WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND TO BE RESPECTFUL
COMMITTEE SIGN LIKE TO READ INTO
THE RECORD THE SUPPORTERS FOR
EIGHTY TWO FIVE SIX SIX. SIX
EIGHT. BECAUSE THEY LOS RIOS
ANGELENOS FOR TREES HARPER PRO
ASSOCIATION FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
AND OUTDOOR EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA GREENWORKS CALIFORNIA
RELIEF CALIFORNIA URBAN FOREST
COUNCIL AND THE SEVEN ASSOCIATED
REGIONAL COUNCILS. HE CENTER FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HEALTH CENTER
FOR REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE
CLIMATE ACTION NOW MANY FORCING
VISOR COMMITTEE DAVEY RESOURCE
GROUP BOB BROOKLYN CONSERVANCY
FOREVER BALBOA PARK STREET
SCHOOLYARDS AMERICA GROWING
TOGETHER INTERNATIONAL SOCIETY
OF A POOR CULTURE WESTERN
CHAPTER THREE TOWN YOU THINK
COMMUNITY CENTER L. A.
NEIGHBORHOOD MANIFEST LATINO
OUTDOORS LOS ANGELES
BEAUTIFICATION TEAM. LUMBER
CYCLE NORTHEAST TREES ARE CITY
FOREST SACRAMENTO TREE
FOUNDATION SUSTAINABLE CLAREMONT
TEN STRANDS THREE FRESNO TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND THREE PARTNERS
FOUNDATION THE WILD WOODS
FOUNDATION AND YOUR CHILDREN.
STREET ALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. AND IT WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THAT THE- ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER SEYARTO. SO I
DIDN'T HEAR ANY WATER DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS- IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS YOU
KNOW IN THE LAST FORTY YEARS-
HAVE AND HAVING ALL OF OUR
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND SCHOOLS
INCLUDING SCHOOLS SCALE DOWN
THEIR USE OF WATER. AND A LOT OF
THAT LED TO. YOU KNOW BASICALLY
THE PLAYGROUNDS THAT WERE
PAVEMENT INSTEAD OF GRASS IN THE
GRASS DIDN'T LAST THAT LONG
ANYWAY SO HOW DO YOU WORK WITH
THE WATER DISTRICTS- TO NOT.
IMPACT THE SCHOOLS FINANCIALLY
BECAUSE THAT WAS A HUGE BILL
THAT WAS ONE OF THE INCENTIVES
FOR THEM NOT TO HAVE ANY MORE
WAS BECAUSE WATER. KEPT
ESCALATING IN AND AS LESS AND
LESS WATER IS AVAILABLE TO BE
ABLE TO- AT GROVE YOU KNOW AND
URBAN FOREST- IT IT SEEMS LIKE
IT MIGHT BE A WASTE OF TIME-
BECAUSE WE KEEP GOING BACK AND
FORTH. BETWEEN THE TWO- IT'S NOT
A WASTE OF TIME TO YOU KNOW I
OBVIOUSLY BE GREAT TO HAVE THESE
FOR US BUT IT IT IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE IT'S REALISTIC IN THE WORLD
WE LIVE IN WITH THE WATER. AND
AND THE EFFORT THAT HAS GONE ON
FOR THE LAST FORTY YEARS TO GET
AWAY FROM THAT USE OF WATER
BECAUSE OF THE EXPENSE AND THE
LACK OF THE RESOURCE ITSELF SO
HOW DO YOU GUYS IN THAT INDUSTRY. DEAL WITH THAT PART OF IT. AT
THE YOU FOR THE QUESTION- ON
BEHALF OF TREAT PEOPLE I WOULD
SAY THAT- THE APPROACH THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON IS
TAKING HERE BY LEVERAGING
EXISTING PROGRAMS. ACTUALLY DOES
A GOOD JOB OF ADDRESSING THAT
VERY CONCERNED- AND IT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT- I
THINK SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS WELL
AS NON PROFITS THAT ARE WORKING
ON. EXPANDING SCHOOL GREENING-
TO SCHOOLS LIKE THEY DON'T HAVE
IT IT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY HAVE
TO SOLVE FOR. WITHIN THE
EXISTING URBAN AND COMMUNITY
FORESTRY PROGRAM AND URBAN
GREENING THINGS LIKE-
UTILIZATION OF BIO SWALES AND
CISTERNS AS A WAY OF CAPTURING
WHENEVER THERE IS. A HEAVY
DELUDE CAPTURING AS MUCH OF THAT
STORMWATER ON SITE. TO BE ABLE
TO USE IT WITHIN THE IRVING
READING LANDSCAPE. IT IS A KEY
COMPONENT SOMETHING THAT- I
THINK A LOT OF THE PROJECT THAT
WE'VE SEEN. HAVE- ALWAYS
INCORPORATED AS A WAY OF
ADDRESSING A PART OF THAT THE
OTHER PART IS ADDRESSED BY-
UTILIZATION OF. SOME BEST
PRACTICES AROUND WHICH KINDS OF
PLANTS WHICH KIND OF TREES ARE
THE MOST APPROPRIATE ESPECIALLY
AS OUR CLIMATE IS CHANGING.
UTILIZING EXAMPLES AND OTHER
STATES LIKE SAY ARIZONA WHERE. I
THINK AS AS WE CAN ALL IMAGINE
SIMILAR ISSUES AROUND WATER
SCARCITY AND HOW YOU PRIORITIZE-
MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE. AND THEN
I THINK AS WE'VE HEARD YOU KNOW
THAT THERE'S THAT THE BROADER
IMPLICATION OF. HOW ARE WE GOING
TO PRIORITIZE THE SCHOOL
GREENING- VERSUS OTHER COMPETING
USES AND I THINK HERE YOU KNOW
THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF
BENEFITING STUDENTS IS ONE THAT.
IS DRIVING US FORWARD IN THIS
CONVERSATION. OKAY ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY WELL I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MISS
CALDERON- FOR WORKING ON HIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE YOU KNOW YEARS A
FEW YEARS AGO I WORKED ON A
SIMILAR BILL- AND UNFORTUNATELY
IT WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR-
AND I WANNA MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT. IF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS HEARING THIS-
YOU KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW THEY'LL
HEAR WHY THIS SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY THIS YEAR WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF- IN THE VETO
MESSAGE OF MY BILL- THAT THE I
WAS TOLD THAT THE STATE WAS
ALREADY INVESTING IN AN OUTDOOR
EQUITY GRANTS PROGRAM WHILE I AM
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT GRANT
PROGRAM. WHAT IT DOES IS TAKE
STUDENTS THAT LIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- THAT SUFFER FROM
EXTREME HATE TO HAVE VERY LITTLE
GREEN SPACE TAKE THEM OUT ON A
FIELD TRIP. YOU KNOW SOMEWHERE
FAR AWAY FROM HOME WHICH IS I
THINK A GREAT EXPERIENCE BUT
IT'S NOT THE SAME AS HAVING
ACCESS TO GREEN SPACE EVERY DAY
IN YOUR COMMUNITY THIS IS LIKE A
BASIC RIGHT YOU KNOW I GREW UP-
ATTENDING LAUSD SCHOOLS WITH
VERY LITTLE GREEN SPACE SO
YOU'RE FORCED TO GO OUT AND PLAY
IN THE YARD. IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY WHICH IS ONE OF THE
HOTTEST AREAS OF LOS ANGELES A
WITH NO SHAPE NO ACCESS TO SHADE
AND YOU HAVE TO BE OUT THERE MAY
THERE IS NO OTHER OPTION- AND SO
I THINK THAT THIS IS WHY I THINK
THIS BILL SHOULD BE A PRIORITY
FOR THE GOVERNOR- THIS YEAR- AND
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT- AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS-
TO. THE ASSEMBLY AND I WOULD
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WITH I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU ON IS A
CO AUTHOR AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NAY VOTE. K. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM MISTER
MURATSUCHI SECONDED BY MISS
BURKE BOERNER HORVATH. I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
EDUCATION COMMITTEE CHAIR RIVAS
I REQUEST HI FLORA. FLORA AYE
BOERNER HORVATH TIME
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY THANK MCCARTY
GAMER TWO G. RIGHT SO I SEYARTO
. NOT VOTING STONE STONE I WOULD
WOOD I. THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES
BELIEVE IT OPENED FOR MEMBERS
THAT ARE MISSING THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. SPOONS. THIS
CALL WAITING FOR AUTHORS I DON'T
SEE ANY IN THE ROOM I BELIEVE
SORRY I CAN'T SEE THAT FAR BACK
TO THIRD AND NO NO AUTHORS BACK
THERE. OKAY MISTER SANTIAGO MISS
WICKS THERE ARE BUT WE HAVE OUT
MISTER MURATSUCHI LET'S GO AHEAD
AND CAN DO YOUR BILL. SO THIS IS
ITEMS SIXTEEN. AB. TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN. WHO WILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERYMUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN-
FIRST I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ALTHOUGH I
WOULD LIKE TO- STATE TO THAT
THAT I DO BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
TO PRIORITIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS- EFFORT FOR WHAT FOR
PREVENTION AND SO- I WILL AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- SUGGESTS A
CONTINUE TO- WORK WITH THE
CURRENT. DEPUTY DIRECTOR. I'LL
COMMITTEE WATER PREPAREDNESS- TO
IT TO SEE. HOW WE CAN WORK WITH-
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. MR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD- THIS IS BUILDING ON YOUR
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE- TO ADDRESS
AN ISSUE THAT- THAT I AND I'M
SURE MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE REPEATEDLY HEARD-
THE MULTIPLE- GREEN TAPE AS AS
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- CALLS
OUT- DIFFERENT AGENCIES- HAVING
TO. HAVE THEIR HANDS- IN THIS
ERMITTING PROCESS FOR THE
IMPORTANT WILDFIRE PREVENTION
MITIGATION EFFORTS FOR SPENDING
OF COURSE MANAGEMENT- AND SO
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
STREAMLINE THAT EFFORT AND TO
HIGHLIGHT IS IMPORTANCE HERE TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS JOHN ANDERSON WITH HUMBOLDT
REDWOOD COMPANY. HI MAN CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. S. ALSO A
LICENSED FORESTER IN THE STATED
JUSTICE MAYES ME EVERY SUMMER WE
ALL SEE WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR
WOODS FOR LOSING MILLIONS OF
ACRES- WE'VE ONLY GOT ABOUT
THIRTY TWO MILLION ACRES IN THE
STATE SO YOU CAN KIND OF DO THE
MATH AND SEE THAT BOY. IF WE
KEEP GOING AT THE RATE WE'RE
GOING. WE'RE GONNA BE IN DIRE
STRAITS HERE IN THE STATE. SO WE
DO NEED TO GET TO THIS GOAL THAT
THE STATE HAS A FIVE THOUSAND
ACRES AS SOON AS PART. AND WE
NEED TO GET TO IT WITH
MEANINGFUL ACRES- AND WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT YOU SEE PART.
THINKING ABOUT COUNTING AT LEAST
AT THE STATE LEVEL FOR. TO MEET
THIS GOAL AND THE REASON THAT'S
IN THERE IS. THAT WE'VE HAD
TIMBER HARVEST PERMITS FOR FORTY
FIVE YEARS OR SO AND THE
WILDFIRE SITUATIONS JUST GOTTEN
WORSE OVER. GOOD TO BE TRUE
ABOUT MEETING IN THE SCHOOL WE
NEED TO DO IT WITH- GRANT
PROJECTS OTHER PERMITS OUTSIDE
OF THE TIMBER HARVEST PERMITS
AT- WE USE TODAY. AND ON TOP
THESE WHAT IRIS- WE JUST HEARD
IT FOR THE FORESTRY MEETING-
THAT JUST LAST MONTH ABOUT THE
OF FORCE PASSED REPORT. AND THE
NUMBER OF DEAD TREES WE HAVE IN
THIS YEAR IS THERE NOW- YOU KNOW
THAT'S UP TO A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DEAD TREES NOW ON
TOP OF THE WILDFIRE IMPACTS WE
REALLY NEED TO GET TO THIS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE GOAL
QUICKLY. AND WE NEED TO.
PRIORITIZE THESE PROJECTS AND SO
THAT'S WHAT- THIS PERSON WOULD
DO- IS HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
PRIORITIZE ALL THOSE PROJECTS TO
TRY AND GET TO AT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND HER GOAL- WITH GETTING
FULL PROJECTS. SO I RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESS REGISTER AN OFFICE. SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT TO.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. STARTING IN THE
HEARING ROOM. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAUL MASON WITH
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST WERE
ACTUALLY A SUPPORT AS AMENDED
POSITION. SORRY IT'S- BEEN
AWHILE- WHICH WAS REALLY I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO BE INCREASING THE SCALE
AND THE OFFICIALS SAY THEY WERE
GETTING TO KNOW THE SORT OF.
ACTUALLY MANAGE PROJECTS BUT
CALIFORNIA IS FUNDAMENTALLY A
FIRE ADAPTED ECOSYSTEM AND UNTIL
WE REALLY ADVANCE ON PUTTING
MORE GOOD FIRE ON THE LANDSCAPE
AND CHANGING HOW WE APPROACH
FIRE WE WILL NEVER GET. THIS
PROBLEM. THE WILL SEE SOME OF
THAT IN THE BILL THAT DOCTOR WAS
PRESENTING LATER BUT THAT WAS
THE- IF AMENDED PART OF OUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. K.
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THE EURO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM
LINE THIRTY ONE. THE THIRTY ONE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. SORRY ABOUT
THAT- GOOD AFTERNOON- CAN HELP
YOU KNOW REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY-
WE ARE IN A SIMILAR POSITION
WITH THE PACIFIC FOREST TRUST-
AND WOULD ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE COMMENTS WE ARE IN A SUPPORT
AMENDED PETITION- AND- WE WOULD
DO WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR. MAY MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS CONSISTENT AGAIN
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY A PALM
EIGHT SUMMIT PFT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IT WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THAT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING
NONE OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR HALF OF
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISTER MATHIS SECOND BY MISTER
SEYARTO. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR RIVAS HI RIVAS I FLORA
FLORA I'VE BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN. YEAH
HI GARCIA I MATHIS MATHIS AND
MCCARTY RIGHT MCCARTY A
MURATSUCHI HI NANCY G. ICR TWO.
ZERO SO I STONE. STONE I WOULD.
WOOD HI. THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN AT THANK YOU. MISTER WHAT ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- FIRST BY LIKE
TO START BATES EXCEPT IN THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL. MEMBERS THE WILDFIRE
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA HAS
IMPACTED ALL OF US.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS CRISIS TOOK
DECADES TO DEVELOP AND IT WILL
TAKE US AT LEAST THAT LONG TO
CORRECT. AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
NINE REQUIRES NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA TO FOCUS ON
LONG TERM OUTCOMES IN OUR
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS. THERE
IS PERHAPS NO STEP MORE CRITICAL
TO CHANGING THE CURRENT FIRE
RISK ACROSS CALIFORNIA THEN
DRAMATICALLY INCREASING THE USE
OF PRESCRIBED FIRE. THE FOREST
MANAGEMENT PASSPORT HAS TO TASK
FORCES SET TARGETS FOR
CALIFORNIA BURNED FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRES- ANNUALLY STARTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THIS BILL
CODIFIES THAT GOAL REQUIRES
CHALFORD REPORT WHAT STEPS IT
INTENDS TO TAKE TO MEET THAT
GOAL. SECOND THIS BILL FOLLOWS
UP ON A PIECE OF MY LEGISLATION
THAT REQUIRED THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR FOREST
AND WATERSHED RESTORATION IN
ORVILLE SHASTA AND TRINITY
WATERSHEDS. THIS BILL WAS SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR BROWN
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND
UNFORTUNATELY SEEMS TO HAVE
FALLEN BY THE WAYSIDE. FINALLY
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY NINE
REQUIRES STATE AGENCIES TO
PRIORITIZE RESTORATION PROJECTS
THAT ENSURE THE PROJECT AREA
WILL MAINTAIN THE DESIRED
CONDITIONS. OTHER WORDS ARE
GOING TO SPEND PUBLIC'S DOLLAR
PUBLIC DOLLARS ON RESTORING
LANDSCAPES AND ECOSYSTEMS. WE
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZING THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WON'T TURN INTO
A STRIP MALL THE CLEAR CUT. WERE
A FIRE HAZARD FIVE YEARS FROM
NOW. ALLISER SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS- HOW THIS WILL BE OCT
ACCOMPLISHMENT COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE AGENCY. AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THERE ARE
NO UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. HERE
TO TESTIFY SUPPORT IS PAUL MASON
WITH PACIFIC FOREST TRUST.
MORNING UP ON MASON WITH THE
POOREST TRUST- THIS IS AN AREA
OF POLICIES EVOLVING VERY VERY
QUICKLY RIGHT NOW EXPECTED THE
WORLD WILL LOOK DIFFERENT AFTER
THE MAY REVISE AND AFTER THE
JUNE BUDGET AND IT'S WILL
PROBABLY CONTINUE TO BE AN
EVOLVING CONVERSATION TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT- THE
AUTHOR HAD REFERENCE THERE. I
THINK AT THE CORE IS HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO REALLY DRIVE TOWARDS
HAVING MORE GOOD FIRE ON THE
LANDSCAPE THE PERVERSE OUTCOME
OF SPENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR ON FIRE SUPPRESSION IS
WORTH LOOKING FOR THE MOST
DAMAGING FIRES. AND SO WE REALLY
NEED TO AS A STATE GET OUR HEAD
AROUND HOW DO WE HAVE MORE FIRE
THAT HAS THE SORT OF OUTCOMES ON
THE LANDSCAPE THAT WE WANT. AND
WE'RE THIS BILL CODIFIES THE
TARGETS THAT- ARE IN THE
RECENTLY RELEASED ACTION PLAN
WHICH ARE MODEST BUT THEN SETS
MORE ASPIRATIONAL TARGETS ON FOR
TWENTY THIRTY. AND ALSO AS THE
AUTHOR NOTED BACK IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE COLLABORATED ON
TRYING TO HAVE THE STATE COME UP
WITH A PLAN FOR THOSE MOST
IMPORTANT WATERSHEDS THAT FORM
THE BACKBONE OF THE STATE AND
FEDERAL WATER SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT HAS JUST
VANISHED. AND NOT COME TO
FRUITION SO I THINK MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY PRIORITIZING
IN THOSE AREAS THAT ARE SO
IMPORTANT AND THEN FINALLY
PRIORITIZING THE SORTS OF
INVESTMENTS THERE CAN HAVE
TERRIBLE OUTCOMES AND NOT SAY WE
CAN'T FIND THINGS THAT DON'T
HAVE GUARANTEES OF LONG TERM
POSITIVE MANAGEMENT BUT THAT WE
EMPHASIZE THOSE THAT DO. THANK
YOU- SO WE ARE READY FOR.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. FOR STARTING IN
THE HEARING ROOM. THANKS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES AND
WE APPRECIATE DR WHICH
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WE DISEASE- SUBMIT
A SUPPORT OF AMENDED LETTER
THANK YOU. OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY NINE. HIS BIGGEST BORDER
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT
THIS TIME. BILL FIRST GO TO LINE
THIRTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR KIM
DELFINO REPRESENTING DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NEED A PLANT THAT THE SOCIETY-
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN NINE THANK YOU. WE HAVE
ONE MORE LINE IN Q. ONE WHAT
WHAT WHAT WE PROVIDE THEIR LINE
NUMBER. WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ELAINE ORTIZ ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION PART. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER LIVES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. YOU SEEN NONE OF DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. SECOND OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
GARCIA SECONDED BY
MISPRONOUNCING KATERI PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS JERRY THIS HI
RIVAS HI FLORA FLORA AYE
BOERNER HORVATH I REMEMBER BEST
HI FRIEDMAN. GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE MATHIS. MCCARTY HI MCCARTY
GOING WEIRD SUJI. SEYARTO THEY
ARE TO KNOW SYSTEM STONE AYE
WOULD I'D WOULD I. THE BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
CAN. SO WEARE WE HAVE TO BILLS
LEFT TO BE HEARD WE'RE WAITING
FOR MR SANTIAGO. AND MISS WICKS. WELL TO BE FIXED TWO ADULTS.
YEAH SO LET'S GO AHEAD WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE AUTHORS
WILL GO HEAD AND- DO ADD ONS.
YEAH LET'S START FROM THE TOP
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO. SO. OKAY GOING. OKAY SO WE'LL
START WIT ITEM ONE AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY. ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA I
MURATSUCHI. I DON'T WANT WERE
ADDING ON THIS. THAT HAS AS NINE
VOTES WITH A BIT OF WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN. I DON'T TO AB. TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY SIX. THAT WOULD BE
HISTORY OKAY WE DON'T NEED THAT
TO SPLIT NEEDS FRIEDMAN. WE I AM
pTHE MOST IN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN. YEP HI GARCIA
I. THAT HAS TEN VOTES WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN. I DON'T FIVE AB TWENTY
SIX OH ONE. WHICH IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MURATSUCHI K. SIX THAT HAS SIX
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN. IDM
SIX AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
GRAYSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
RIVAS HI RIVAS I FRIEDMAN. YEAH
GARCIA HI. THE BILL HAS TEN
VOTES WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN. IN
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN WHO WERE GOOD. SORRY I
MEANT ITEM TEN AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR RIVAS HI RIVAS I FRIEDMAN. GARCIA GARCIA I. THAT HAS TEN
VOTES FOR WILL LEAVE IT OPEN.
CONSENT.
NEVER MIND CONSENT. WORK WILL DO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE FRIEDMAN. GARCIA
GARCIA I MURATSUCHI. BUT STILL
HAS NOT THAT HAS NOW HAS NINE
VOTES BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN.
OKAY I THINK WE'VE GONE THROUGH
ALL OF THEM WAITING FOR MR
SANTIAGO. AND MISS WICKS. WITH.
OR.
EXACTLY YEAH I DID WANT TO
LAUNCH YOUR MYSELF BUT THEN I.
YEAH RIGHT. YEAH THAT'S RIGHT
OVER THAT DOESN'T MATTER HELLO.
YEAH HAVE YOUR YEAH. YEAH I.
WILL RIGHT. OKAY THERE'S
TRANSPORTATION. OKAY.
OKAY YEAH. YEAH. RIGHT REPORTER. THAT'S ONE OF THE- STATE. YEAH. OKAY OKAY- WHY SHOULD COUNTY
COMMUNITY LEADERS. OKAY. OKAY
THIS LOCAL EXISTENCE- YEAH. ONE
ONE OF THE YEAH. YEAH. OKAY THAT
WILL BE. OKAY.
UHHUH. UHHUH UHHUH UHHUH OKAY.
YEAH.
YES WILL MOVE ON TO. BUT FOR THE
- BY KEVIN. YEAH I MISS YOU TOO
OF SO WE WILL MOVE TO ITEM
TWELVE AB. EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS. WHEN I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK AND CONSIDERATION OF THIS
BILL AND I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. AND THE BAY
AREA REFINERIES ARE SOME OF THE
LARGEST SOURCES OF POLLUTION
I'VE ONE OF THEM IN MY DISTRICT
AND I'M GETTING ANOTHER ONE WITH
REDISTRICTING. OVERALL
COMPLIANCE WITH AIR QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS HAVE DECLINED IN
RECENT YEARS WITH INCREASING
FLARING EVENTS. SPECIFICALLY IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE BAY AREA
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
ISSUED OVER TWO HUNDRED FORTY
NOTICES OF VIOLATIONS TO BAY
AREA REFINERIES. THE INCREASE
FLOODING EVENTS AND DECLINE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH AIR QUALITY
REGULATIONS HAVE SEVERE IN HAVE
SEVERE IMPACTS. ON THESE
COMMUNITIES AS THEY- EXPOSE-
THESE COMMUNITIES MY COMMUNITIES
TO TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS WHICH
LEAD TO SHELTER IN PLACE
NOTIFICATIONS. AND INCREASED
HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS.
SPECIFICALLY IN MY DISTRICT
THERE HAVE BEEN INCREASES IN AIR
POLLUTION COMPLAINTS THE LACK OF
COMPLIANCE AND INCREASE FLARING
EVENTS HAVE LED TO. A INCIDENCES
THAT HAVE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
THE HEALTH OF THE COMMUNITY AND
IMPACTED SCHOOLS IN THE
SURROUNDING AREAS. TO ADDRESS
THE OVERALL DECLINE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH AIR QUALITY
REGULATIONS HE EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN WILL INCREASE THE CIVIL
PENALTY PENALTY CEILINGS FOR
VIOLATIONS OF STATE. OR LOCAL
AIR QUALITY RULES TO THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF THE
VIOLATION RESULTS DISRUPTIONS
COMMUNITY. CIVIL WE WILL ALSO BE
USED. TO ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PROVIDE. FOR SUBSEQUENT
VIOLATIONS WITHIN A TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD. I WANT TO THANK THE
BILL'S SPONSORS THE BAY AREA.
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND I WILL
LET ME WITNESSES HERE SELF AND-
SELF I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M ALLEN ABS
REPRESENTING THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
SPONSOR OF AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
REFINERY COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST CUMULATIVE
HEALTH BURDENS IN CALIFORNIA
EVEN IN CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE
REFINERIES ARE OPERATING WITHIN
ALL THEIR PERMIT CONDITIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY REFINERIES DON'T
ALWAYS OPERATE WITHIN THEIR
PERMIT CONDITIONS IN IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ALONE THE AIR
DISTRICT ISSUED OVER TWO HUNDRED
FORTY NOTICES OF VIOLATION.
REFINERY COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
ALSO EXPERIENCED AT LEAST THIRTY
FLARING EVENTS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THIS IS ACTUALLY A DECREASE
IN FLARING COMPARED TO TWENTY
NINETEEN ONE REFINERY
COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCED SEVENTY
TWO FLARING EVENTS. THAT'S A
FLARING EVENT EVERY FIVE DAYS
WHERE YOU MIGHT BE TOLD TO STAY
INSIDE YOUR CHILD MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL OR YOU
MIGHT HAVE TO SEEK MEDICAL CARE
BECAUSE OF EXCESS EMISSIONS OF
SULFUR OXIDES PARTICULATE MATTER
<c.red>N TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS. THE</c>
PENALTY SEALING FOR THESE EVENTS
WITH TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWO
THOUSAND. AND IS RISEN ONLY 9%
AND TWENTY TWO YEARS. IMAGINE
BEING A REFINERY COMMUNITY
RESIDENT AND KNOWING THAT THIS
TYPE OF DESTRUCTION IN YOUR
COMMUNITY IS ONLY WORTH SLIGHTLY
OVER A TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE.
IN THE COMPANIES MAKING RECORD
PROFITS. I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN ALL THREE NAY BE
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN WHICH
TAKES A SMALL STEP TOWARDS
BETTER ALIGNING PENALTIES FOR
REFINERIES VIOLATING AIR QUALITY
PERMITS. CAUSING COMMUNITY
DESTRUCTIONS IN ENDANGERING
PUBLIC HEALTH AB EIGHTEEN NOT
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN PROPOSES A
MODEST INCREASE TO THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR CERTAIN
PENALTIES AT REFINERIES. IN A
FURTHER INCREASE FOR REPETITIVE
VIOLATIONS THE BURDEN REFINERY
COMMUNITIES WHILE THESE MODEST
AMOUNTS CAN'T FULLY MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS IN THESE COMMUNITIES WE
HOPE IT DISCOURAGES THINKING
ABOUT THESE EVENTS AS A MINOR
COST OF DOING BUSINESS. THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS BILL
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT. I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL.
PENALTIES NEED TO BE HIGH ENOUGH
TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR AND- AND
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE NOT. AND THEY
HAVEN'T EVEN KEPT PACE WITH
INFLATION AND THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE REAL. PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO
BREATHE UNHEALTHY AIR. BECAUSE
OF VIOLATIONS BY THE REFINERIES
SO THIS BILL WOULD TAKE A STEP
TOWARDS CORRECTING THAT- YOU
KNOW IT MAY BE THAT THE FAMILY
SHOULD BE EVEN HIGHER BUT- WE
SUPPORT THIS AS A- SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT. ON THE STATUS QUO
SO WE URGE YOU TO PASS IT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU UP NEXT WE
HAVE A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION-
MISTER ZACHARY LEARY FROM THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SACKLER
ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION- WE HAVE
RESPECTFULLY TAKEN A OPPOSE
POSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN OUR CONCERNS CAN BROADLY
BE BROKEN DOWN INTO THREE
CATEGORIES. OF FIRST THE BILL
ARBITRARILY RAISES THE PENALTIES
UP FROM 1-000-023-0000 WHICH IS
2100% INCREASE- SECOND OUR
CONCERN IS WITH REGARDS TO THE
DEFINITION THAT WOULD TRIGGER
THESE PENALTIES- BY INCLUDING
BROAD LANGUAGE OF DISRUPTION TO
THE COMMUNITY THAT. SEEMS A BIT
SUBJECTIVE TO WIN THESE
PENALTIES WOULD BE INCREASED
THEN PLIED IN SITUATIONS UP ON
THE STATE- AND THEN FINALLY THE
BILL SETS A NEW PRECEDENT WITH
REGARDS TO A SINGLE IT SINGLING
OUT A SINGLE INDUSTRY WITH
REGARDS TO AIR VIOLATIONS- THIS
NEW BILL CREATES NOW A TWO TIER.
SYSTEM WITHIN THE PENALTY
STRUCTURE TRADITIONALLY THOSE
HAVE APPLIED EQUALLY ACROSS
TITLE FIVE FACILITIES- UNDER
THIS NEW APPROACH YOU'LL SEE
SIMILARLY SITUATED TITLE FIVE
PERMIT HOLDERS- TREATED
DIFFERENTLY FOR SIMILAR SIMILAR
AIR QUALITY VIOLATION- THIS WILL
NOW CREATE A PIECEMEAL APPROACH
WITHIN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE AS A- AS IT PERTAINS TO
THE- PENALTIES WITH REGARD TO-
AIR QUALITY. UNFORTUNATELY WITH
THE S. THREE I BOUGHT A YEAR NO
VOTE TODAY. TO NO VOTE TODAY ON
A V. EIGHT NINETIES. THANK YOU
I'VE NEXT RAY FOR A WEIGHT
STARTING IN THE HEARING ROOM.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CLOSE MORE YAMA HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC BALANCE
FOR THE REASONS STATED BY MY
COLLEAGUE WAS SPOKE WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN THEIR
JOURNAL ABOUT. FULL OF CRAP WE
HAVE THE SOUTH COAST AT UT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. K.
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF. AB SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT
THIS TIME. OF YEAR TO SMOKE. WE
DO HAVE LINES QUEUING UP WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT WE PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBERS. THE FIRST GO TO
LINE THIRTY NINE GO AHEAD. KAREN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM THE
OPEN MARKET WHERE ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE-
HELLO THIS IS- STEVEN ROSENBAUM-
I'M A RESIDENT OF PALO ALTO AND
I'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB CA NINETY SEVEN THANK. NINE
FIVE. THIS IS JUDY SORRY I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH THREE FIVE GOAL
BAY AREA ACTION ON BEHALF OF OUR
TWELVE THOUSAND SUPPORTERS WE
SUPPORT AB. EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. BY. TWENTY SIX.
IT OPENS. GO AHEAD- JIM WARREN-
PLAN TO SUPPORT AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY SEVEN TO REDUCING IMPACTS
ON OUR COMMUNITIES. IN THE BAY
AREA PARTICULARLY IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY THANK YOU CAN MOURN
. FISHERMEN HAVE LOWER DOSAGE OF
THIS TIME. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS RICHARD
BYRD- THIS SORRY ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON THE
LINES. PARDON ME I JUST CRIED TO
MYSELF IS THAT THAT I'M SURE
RATHER ON MY APOLOGIES. OKAY OF
ANY AS ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
GARCIA I WANT TO MOVE THE BILL
AND THANK YOU FOR THIS- AND
ADDRESS SOMETHING I HEARD IN THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT TARGETING AN
INDUSTRY WE DO THAT OFTEN- IN
THIS IN THIS BUILDING BUT I HAVE
BEEN FOLLOWING CLOSELY THE NEWS
FOR MULTIPLE YEARS NOW OF WHAT'S
BEEN GOING ON WITH THE REFINERY
FROM THE BAY AREA SPECIFICALLY.
THE CONSTANT OUT OF ITS DISTRICT
SLATE IN THIS REGARD OR NOT BUT
- THE CURRENT SYSTEM ISN'T
WORKING AND IT'S NOT MAKING
THINGS BETTER OUT THERE AND SO-
I APPRECIATE THAT. THAT YOU'RE
DOING THIS BILL TODAY AND I
THINK IT BEST PART THAT WE FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS INDUSTRY
AND WITH THAT I'D MOVE THE BILL
. OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. OKAY OF YOU I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL-
AND THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT PROPOSED THAT
THE PENALTY PROCEEDS GO TOWARDS
MITIGATING AIR POLLUTION IN THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITY THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW A LOT OF
MEMBERS IN THE PAST HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR- AND SO THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS IT'S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO WE HAVE A SECOND. CAN
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO JUDICIARY. JERRY BUSS HI
RIVAS HI FLORA. FLOOR NO
BOERNER HORVATH. BOERNER HORVATH
I FRIEDMAN GARCIA. AYE GARCIA
AYE MATHIS. MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I SAY
ARE TO. THEY ARE NO STONE. STONE
I WOULD WOOD I. THE BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTES BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR. THE NEXT AND
FINAL BILL. ITEM ELEVEN AB
TWENTY NINE TEN BY MR SANTIAGO.
FOR MEMBERS.
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR THANK YOU
THANK MENTORED PRESS LIKE TO
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS AND THINK IF
YOU AND YOUR STAFF ON THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
INPUT HELPING TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER BILL AND THE STREET FOR
WHAT WE'RE- WHAT WE WANT TO DO
BASICALLY IS. IN PREVENT THE
CONTINUING CARE VIOLATIONS ARE
HAPPENING WITHIN. OUR
COMMUNITIES I SHOULD PROBABLY
STEP BACK FOR A SECOND AND
THINK. MISTER SEA IN THE SUMMERS
WE KEEP A CO AUTHOR IN THE BILL.
AND THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS OVER
THE YEARS. UPDATED HERE FOR
EXAMPLE IT'S JUST THE PREVENT
AIR QUALITY VIOLATIONS- THAT ARE
HAPPENING. IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
IN A PERFECT WORLD WE WOULD-
HAVE THE CURRENT- THE CURRENT
PENALTIES AND WE WOULD HAVE-
VIOLATIONS BUT THE REALITY THAT
THEY BECOME JUST. A WAY OF DOING
BUSINESS THAT IS IN THAT THE-
VIOLATIONS JUST ABSORB. AND IT'S
NOT DETERRING- THE AIR QUALITY
VIOLATIONS AND CONSEQUENTLY IT'S
HORTON- OUR COMMUNITIES AT
CERTAIN OUR KIDS WHEN THEY'RE
HAVING A BRIEF OR SMELL- THESE
HORRIFIC- EITHER POLLUTANTS. OR
SMELLED IN THE AIR OUR AREA FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE. FIVE VIOLATORS
WHO. OUTSIDE OF THE- EXCITE AND
OTHERS THAT YOU. ALL HAVE HEARD
ME TALK ABOUT OVER THE YEARS.
BUT BY RENDERING PLANTS HAVE
NOT. A DECREASE THEIR AIR
QUALITY VIOLATIONS- AND JUST
CONTINUE TO ABSORB- THE CURRENT-
PENALTIES. SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS INCREASE IT AND THANK YOU FOR
HELPING US BOTH ON THE STRIP
CLUB BILLION AND NEGLIGENCE WITH
THE OF THE AMENITY RECOMMENDED.
WHICH WE HOPE WILL DETOUR. BUT
IF NOT BE ABLE TO PENALIZE THEM-
SO THAT THEY DON'T DO THIS- I
UNDERSTAND ALL BUT WE'RE STILL
GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK ON
LANGUAGE- THAT REFLECT WHAT YOU
AND I TALKED ABOUT WHICH WAS THE
MOST IMPACTED. COMMUNITIES
PARTICULAR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES RECEIVED- THOSE
DOLLARS- THOSE DOLLARS THAT ARE
OFF. SO THAT WE- AIM TO DO IN
END TO WE WANT TO DO IS. UP THE
COMMUNITY. WHAT THE MOST
NEGATIVE IMPACTED. SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND- AND I
WOULD LIKE TO HAND OVER TO A
COUPLE ONES THAT WE HAVE THANK
YOU MANAGER. PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON- MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS TERRENCE MANN AND I'M THE
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT AT
SOUTH BECAUSE THEY CAN BE AB
TWENTY NINE TEN WOULD PROVIDE
MORE MEANINGFUL DETERRENCE FOR
AIR QUALITY VIOLATIONS
ESPECIALLY IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- BY RAISING LIMITS
ON CERTAIN CIVIL PENALTIES UNDER
THE EXISTING LAW A COMPANY OR
FACILITY CAN VIOLATE OUR QUALITY
REGULATIONS RULES PERMIT
CONDITIONS AND THEY'RE STRICTLY
LIABLE FOR NO MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THAT'S PER
VIOLATION. PER DAY- AND STRICT
LIABILITY IS THE MOST COMMON-
LEVEL THAT WE USE IN OUR FORCING
ACTIONS ALSO IF A FACILITY OR
COMPANY IS ABLE TO ESTABLISH AN
AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE THAT THEY
WEREN'T NEGLIGENT OR DIDN'T DO
IT INTENTIONALLY THE MAXIMUM
PENALTY GOES DOWN TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND SO WHILE
THESE CAN BE SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS
TO A SMALL MOM AND POP TYPE OF
FACILITY OR COMPANY- IT THERE IS
VERY LITTLE VALUE FORMER TALKING
ABOUT BIG COMPANIES AND WELL
FUNDED VIOLATORS- IT'S REALLY
JUST A SLAP ON THE WRIST REST AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS- AND IT
ALSO DOESN'T MATTER HOW
EXTENSIVE THE AIR QUALITY
VIOLATION IS SO- AS AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AS A MEMBER
SANTIAGO SEES ME- DISCUSSED THE
RENDERING FACILITIES SO THEY
TAKE RAW ANIMAL PARKS. AND THEY
PROCESS THEM IT'S THE SMELL
BASICALLY OF A ROTTING CORPSE
SPREADING A CAR ACROSS NOT JUST
ONE TOWN BUT IT ALMOST OF THE
REGION- AND IT COULD IMPACT
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND THAT'S
JUST TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT'S
IT NO MATTER THE SIZE OF IT AND
SO- WE VIEW THAT AS AS BEING A
SERIOUS PROBLEM- AND THIS BILL
WILL IMPACT PENALTY LIMITS FOR
OTHER KINDS OF FACILITIES AS
WELL OIL AND GAS- CONSTRUCTION
SITES. LANDFILLS POWER PLANTS TO
NAME A FEW AND AS WE ALL KNOW
MANY OF THESE FACILITIES ARE
LOCATED IN SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES- AND I
THINK I WOULD BE REMISS WITHOUT
NOTING. THAT THIS BILL WILL NOT
IMPACT SMALL BUSINESS AND SO THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE ALREADY
INCLUDES- SEVERAL FACTORS THAT
HAVE TO BE- EVALUATED WHEN IN
DETERMINING PENALTIES ONE OF
THEM IS BASICALLY THE ABILITY TO
PAY. THE FINANCIAL BURDEN ON THE
VIOLATING A COMPANY AND THAT
WILL NOT BE CHANGED HERE SO A
SOUTH COAST IT CAN BE WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. WITH THIS
IMPORTANT BILL- THAT WILL HELP
DETER AIR QUALITY VESTED
VIOLATIONS AND PROTECT THE
COMMUNITIES WE ALL SERVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON A
NEW COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON NICOLAS
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT JUST ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY NINE TEN WILL START IN
THE HEARING ROOM. ALLEN AB TO
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CLIFF MORNING I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC BALANCE
WE DID SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE AND TO THE AUTHOR AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
WE DO UNDERSTAND AND THE
REFERENCE TO THE- OF- TO THE
SERVER TYPE REFINERIES THE
RENDERING FACILITIES THAT.
REFERENCED IN THE COMMISSION
HOUSES THAT TRULY THAT CAN BE A
AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM. THE BILL.
TO ALL THE FACILITIES AND THAT'S
WHERE WE HAVE TO DRAW OUR
OPPOSITION BUT WE'D BE HAPPY TO
HAVE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS FOR.
FOCUSING ON THOSE TYPES OF
FACILITIES OF ASK THE IMMEDIATE
PRIORITY AND THEN ALSO AS IT
RELATES TO THE FINES AND
PENALTIES. IT'S A UNDER MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE PENALTIES
WILL INCREASE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
THAT'S INDEXED TO INFLATION.
REGARD ANYWAYS AND SO THERE WILL
BE A CONSTANT. UPGRADING ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS OF THE FINES AND
PENALTIES SO WE WANT TO PUT THAT
AND KEEP THAT IN MIND BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE RENDERING
FACILITIES OF THAT'S FIRST AND
FOREMOST. WE'D LOVE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THAT WITH
THE AUTHOR. BUT CURRENTLY WE
HAVE TO REQUEST AND NO VOTE.
OKAY OF. UP CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY NINE TEN
. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
EIGHTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BY NAME APART BUT-
THE- GATEKEEPER OF EUROPE EIGHTY
NINE POINT ZERO BUT WE- PERRANCE
THE BILL BLACK BASS A PANEL FONG
IN THE- BURKE THE BY MAKE THE-
WE AGREED THAT INCREASE. PENALTY
ABOUT CRITICAL USE ME SADLY YOU
WE'RE JUST TAKING OF YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL NAY MORGUE
AND POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU. BOB THANK. BY TWENTY NINE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS SCOTT
KING WROTE HIM AGAIN FROM PALO
ALTO ON SUPPORTER AB TWENTY NINE
TEN THANK. BOETTICHER WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. MISS GARCIA YEAH THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS AND WHILE THE
RENDERING PLANTS- WERE PART OF
THE MOTIVATION I KNOW IT'S NOT
THE ONLY MOTIVATION BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THAT. THAT WORK IN
THAT WORD GOING WIDER THAN JUST
THOSE ON THE SPENDING PLANS JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE TAKING ALL THE
COOL ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS. YES I THINK THE
CHAIR AND I WAS STILL TALKING
ABOUT- IN TERMS OF HOW THE FUNDS
ARE GONNA BE USE THAT THAT THEY
ARE- TARGETING. A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT WE AGREED
ON CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
PIECE THE LANGUAGE. SUCH AS WE
START AB EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN
AND TWENTY NINE TEN AND WE'VE
GOT SIMILAR SESSIONS ON A FEW
ITEMS. MY TIME HERE ABOUT YOU
SEEN THE DOLLARS AND THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITY. ALMOST
ALWAYS IT'S- IT'S AN R.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
SO. I DO APPRECIATE THAT
COMMITTEES- ATTENTION TO THAT
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AND JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE BEING
CONSISTENT ACROSS ACROSS THE
BILL SINCE I DO APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE TAKING THE MOMENTUM THAT
LANGUAGE AND- NAME ADDRESS. AND
I DON'T MOVE THE BILL. ANY
OTHER. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MISTER
MURATSUCHI. COULD COULD YOU
CLARIFY FOR ME- WHEN THE STRICT
LIABILITY ATTACHED IS WHAT WHAT
WHAT ARE THE MOST COMMON
SCENARIOS FOR STRICT LIABILITY.
GOT THANK YOU TYPICALLY THAT'S
WHEN THERE'S AN ADMINISTRATIVE
TYPE OF FINE SO YOU MISTER
REPORTING A SOURCE TEST- SO
MIDDLE OF A REPORT- THAT'S AT
THE LOWER LEVELS ON AND YOU AND
YOU ONLY GET TO THE SECOND PHASE
OF THE TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. IF
YOU CAN'T SHOW THAT IT WAS
SOMETHING BY- YOU KNOW HONEST
MISTAKE OR OTHERWISE- SO THERE'S
TYPICALLY AN EMISSIONS
VIOLATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
WHERE THERE'S A RELEASE OR
SOMETHING FROM A FACILITY AND WE
CAN MEASURE AND QUANTIFY THE
EMISSIONS- WE WILL GO TO THE
SECOND TIER OF THE- STRUCK
LIABILITY WHICH WOULD BE IN THE
TEN THOUSAND RANGE- BUT THAT'S
THE MOST COMMON VIOLATION
BECAUSE YOU KNOW BUSINESSES ARE
NOT OUT THERE INTENTIONALLY.
COMMITTING ENVIRONMENTAL CRIMES
OR BY MIDDLE OF VIOLATIONS AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE STICK UP OF THE
BOTTOM LEVEL- YOU KNOW REASONS
OF AND SUCH LIKE IN HYPERION-
THEY HAD SOMETHING WHERE THERE
WAS A AN OVERFLOW TO THE SYSTEM
AND SO THAT RESULTED IN FORTY
ONE DAYS. OF VIOLATION BUT IT
WAS NOT SOMETHING WHERE THE
OPERATOR INTENTIONALLY YOU KNOW
WASN'T MAINTAINING THE SYSTEM OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND SO
THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
SAMPLE LIKE THAT. FORTY ONE DAYS
OF VIOLATION MAYBE YOU GET TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS WE DON'T FEEL
THAT THAT'S REFLECTIVE OF THE
TYPE OF IMPACT THAT WOULD HAVE
LIKE ON THE NEARBY CITY LIKE
ALSO. SO IF THERE WAS LIKE A- A
SMALLER OPERATION LIKE. YOU KNOW
NOT A REFINERY BUT- YOU KNOW
THEY THEY THEY THEY WOULD BE
POTENTIALLY HELD LIABLE FOR SOME
OF THESE INCREASE STRICT
LIABILITY PENALTIES KNOW WHAT OF
TERRENCE HAD REFERENCE UNDER
SECTION FOUR TWO FOUR THREE OF
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE THE
LEGISLATURE IDENTIFIES EIGHT
FACTORS AT ALL THE ARE DISTRICTS
POSTED TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATIONS
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE DRY
CLEANER AND GAS STATION. ABILITY
TO PAY IS ONE OF THOSE FACTORS
SO THAT'S ONE THAT- WHEN WE
ENGAGE WITH NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THESE FACILITIES THEY PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION AND WE MITIGATE
THE PENALTY THAT'S REFLECTIVE OF
THEIR THEIR ABILITY TO PAY A
FINE OKAY AND- HOPEFULLY BY
FRIENDS AT THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
HASN'T. FORGOTTEN THE ONGOING
ISSUE OF HYDROCHLORIC ACID AT
THE TORRANCE REFINERY THERE IF
THERE ARE UNPERMITTED EMISSIONS
LEAK LEAK IS OF HYDROCHLORIC
ACID AT THE TORRANCE REFINERY
WOULD THAT WOULD THEY BE SUBJECT
TO THE STRICT LIABILITY HELLO
YES AND YOU YOU BRING UP A GOOD
EXAMPLE THAT'S ONE OF THE CASES
THAT I WOULD RELATE TO THE
MEMBERS THAT WE DO THE SOUTH
BECAUSE HE CAN HE DOES REACT TO
WHEN THERE'S A VIOLATION IN THAT
CASE. IT WAS A FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS SETTLEMENT TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION WENT TO THE
IN THE USED WE CREATED A FUN AND
THAT WAS USED TO CREATE FENCE
LINE MONITORING AT THE FACILITY
SO ON OUR OWN WE UNDERSTAND THE
CHARGE THAT THE ASSEMBLY EXPECTS
OF US IN RE PURPOSING THAT MONEY
BACK FOR THE COMMUNITY AND WE
BELIEVE WE DEFINITELY DELIVERED
IN. THAT CASE OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER. OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY ARE YOU KNOW
THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- YOU KNOW
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS- WE JUST HEARD A BILL
BY MISS WICKS- WHERE SHE ALSO
ACCEPTED SIMILAR AMENDMENTS
PROPOSING THAT THESE PET THE
FUNDS FROM THE PENALTIES- ARE
USED ARE YOU KNOW ARE VESTED IN
THE COMMUNITIES AFFECTED I THINK
IT'S VERY UNLIKELY- THAT THIS
WOULD HAPPEN IN A COMMUNITY THAT
DOESN'T NEED IT. AND I KNOW THAT
IS YOUR CONCERN- WE WILL REVIEW
THE LANGUAGE AND WORK IT OUT IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE- BUT I WANT
TO BE CLEAR- THAT. JUST LIKE THE
OTHER BILL I FEEL THAT THESE
FUNDS THE PROCEEDS SHOULD BE
USED- TO INVEST IN THESE TO
MITIGATE- YOU KNOW THE AIR
POLLUTION. IN IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY WHATEVER VIOLATION A
MAY BE- IT THE FUNDS WILL NOT BE
USED FOR GENERAL OPERATIONS OR-
ANYTHING ELSE AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT SOUTH COAST- YOU KNOW MAYBE
IS NOT STRUCTURE. TO DO THIS BUT
I THINK THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO FINALLY DO THIS- JUST LIKE
THE BAY AREA AQ M. D. HAS
ACCEPTED TO DO THIS I JUST FEEL
THAT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY- IN
THE LAST BILLS A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM SOUTH COAST A. Q. M. D.
CAME UP- TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
AND AT ON IN SUPPORT AND SO I
THINK. THEY SHOULD BE SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS FOR THEIR OWN AGENCY ARE
AND SO I JUST WANT THAT TO BE
CLEAR- THAT WE'RE NOT. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO CHANGE THE LANGUAGE-
TWO OF YOU KNOW GET A Q. AND D.
TEND NOT INVEST IN THE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES. MERS FONG PLEASE GO
AHEAD NOT AND I THINK YOU AND I
SHARE THE SHARE I THINK THE
CONVERSATION IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE FOR
THE BILL IS TO HAVE MOST THE
MONIES- IT AIMED AT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
WHEN WILL THEN JUST IT FOR IN
OUR CONVERSATION JUST TO GET THE
LANGUAGE RIGHT SO THERE MAY BE A
SITUATION. WHERE THERE MAY BE A
VIOLATION OR A SETTLEMENT IN AN
AREA WHERE THAT THE AIR QUALITY
VIOLATIONS HAVE BEEN MITIGATED
IN THOSE DOLLARS WOULD BE IN
EXCESS AND WE CAN RESTRUCTURE
LAWMAKERS IN A WAY THAT THAT
THAT GOES TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND HAS A LARGER
IMPACT- BUT IN NO WAY. AND I
SHARE THE SENTIMENT WITH YOU
THAT IF THE DOLLARS ARE USED IN
THIS I'M SORRY- IF THE
VIOLATIONS COME UP IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY THAT
THAT THE DOLLARS BE USED IN THAT. PARTICULAR AREA HOW 2% OKAY
ALL. MR MERECE SHE HAS A COMMON
THANK I ASK. OF A QUESTION I. AM
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR- BUT-
AS THE HEY KIM SOUTHCOAST A
CANDY REPRESENTATIVE INDICATED.
A PRIME EXAMPLE IS IN TORRANCE
AND I'M NOT SURE F YOUR
DISCUSSIONS. YOU KNOW IT WOULD
INCLUDE A COMMUNITY LIKE
TORRANCE IN A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY ALTHOUGH WE DO CLEARLY
YOU KNOW ARE IMPACTED BY THE AIR
POLLUTION- YOU KNOW. THAT THAT
THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED BY THE
VIOLATIONS SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THAT THE THAT
THE INTENT OF THE AMENDMENT IS
TO. MITIGATE THE AIR POLLUTION
IN THE IMPACTED COMMUNITY AND
NOT NECESSARILY LIMITED TO LIKE
LIKE A CALOMBARIS SCREEN OR
OTHER DEFINITION OF A- VISIT
THIS ADVANCE COMMUNITY YEAH THAT
IS NOT THE INTENTION. RIGHT I
BELIEVE WHAT MR SANTIAGO IS
GOING FOR IS IF THE VIOLATION IS
ALREADY BEEN MITIGATED IN THAT
COMMUNITY- HE WOULD LIKE THE
FUNDS THAN TO BE INVESTED IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. RIGHT
IF RIGHT NOT IF IT'S NOT IF THE
COMMUNITY AFFECTED IS NOT
DISADVANTAGED OKAY RIGHT NOW
CORRECT ABSENT MEANT MANAGEMENT
MENTAL HEALTH. NO ABSOLUTELY
LOOK THE REALITIES IF THE END
AND AT THE BEGINNING BUT LET'S
JUST THE SPONSORS AND I KIND OF
DEPEND ON THAT BUT WE'VE GOTTEN
TO A POINT I THINK WE'RE GONNA
BE OKAY- IF A COMMUNITY. HAS
BEEN IMPACTED. YOU TO CLEAN UP
THAT COMMUNITY NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT. WHAT WHAT THE DOLLARS
MITIGATED IN THAT PARTICULAR
AREA WHETHER IT'S BY FINES OR BY
SETTLEMENT BECAUSE OUR
SETTLEMENT IN SOME CASES- THE
CERTAINLY CAN BE MUCH HIGHER
THAN THE FIND IN MANY CASES. IF
THAT IF WHATEVER AREA HAS BEEN.
CLEANED UP AND YOU CAN CORRECT
ME MANAGER IF YOU THINK I
MISUNDERSTOOD BUT I THINK WE'RE
AIMING AT THE SAME THING. I HOPE
THAT- IT. IF AN AREA IS ALREADY
BEEN CLEANED UP LET'S SAY FOR
EXAMPLE- SANTIAGO SOCIO TO OPEN
UP. A SHOP IN PARTICULAR AREA.
THEY HAVE POLLUTION THAT WE
SETTLED OUT FOR TEN MILLION
BUCKS OR WHATEVER IT IS. AND IT
WAS ALREADY CLEAN. IF THERE'S
EXTRA DOLLARS LEFT OVER WE WOULD
WANT THEM TO GO TO A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. SO THAT
THERE'S THE FLEXIBILITY USED FOR
THAT. LIKEWISE IF THOSE DOLLARS-
ARE. EITHER FIND OR OR SETTLED-
IN THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
THEY SHOULD STATE ISSUE CLEAN UP
THAT THAT POLLUTION I DON'T WANT
THOSE DOLLARS TO LEAVE FROM ANY
PARTICULAR AREA THAT IS
DISADVANTAGED. ANYMORE THAN I
WOULD WANT THEM TO LEAVE FROM
THE AREA- THAT THAT THAT I
REPRESENT- IT WAS JUST A WAY TO
SAY. IT THERE- LET'S LAWLER THEY
COULD USE THE MORE TOWARD THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I
THINK THAT'S- THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE WERE AIMING AT IN TERMS OF
FLEXIBILITY. I THINK. YOU'RE
OKAY WITH THAT I THINK SO. OKAY
OKAY WELL- I THINK ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OKAY DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THIS I THINK WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS GARCIA WE
NEED A SECOND. SECOND BY MISS
BOERNER HORVATH- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I'M NOT SURE IF I GIVE YOU
THAT OPPORTUNITY I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN KEEPING VERY TENTATIVE TIME
TYPE VERY MUCH APPRECIATED MAN
CHEN WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
AND- PERSPECTIVE ENOUGH WHEN
I'VE OPENED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO.
DISH JERRY JERRY LEWIS I'D BE
THIS AYE FLORA. LEARN OR
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS MCCARTY
RIGHT MCCARTY I'M RESEARCHING
RESEARCH I SAY R. TWO ZERO TURN
OF STONE. STONE I WOULD. WOOD I. THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THAT ARE
ABSENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YEAH THE PHONE WHILE A LOT OF.
THE LAST TIME TO STOP HOLD ME
THAT THEY WERE GOING. ALL THE
GIRLS ARE ALL. OKAY YEAH WHAT GO
AHEAD AND- DO ADD ONS I BELIEVE
MISS MERCY HAS THREE BILL FOR
FOUR WITH THREE PLUS THE CONSENT
SO LET'S START WITH ITEM ONE. AB. TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY CHAIR
VOTING BY. ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN MURATSUCHI WHERE TO
CHEAT BY TEN VOTES WOULD AFFECT
THE HAS TEN VOTES WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN ITEMS FIVE. AB TWENTY SIX
ZERO ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING
HI ABSENT MEMBERS. FRIEDMAN
MURATSUCHI TWO GI. WELL HAS
SEVEN VOTES FOR WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN AND ITEM SEVENTEEN WHICH-
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY NINE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN. WHERE
TWO G. MATTEUCCI I. THE BILL HAS
A PULSE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN AND
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN MURATSUCHI
WHERE TO GI NOW BILL HAS TEN
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN. WE
THINK WE JUST WAIT FOR MISS
FRIEDMAN. SO I THINK THAT
EVERYBODY ELSE. BY THE WAY. I
THOUGHT. YEAH UHHUH. FOR YEAH.
SO I HAVE A I THINK IT WAS
WARNING BUT REALITY IS FELT. HI
OKAY. YOU KNOW WHAT I'LL JUST
ASK OKAY TALKING YEAH RIGHT OKAY
YEAH YEAH SERVICES OF THE CENTER. BUDGET IS GOOD OKAY YEAH.
THREE THIS MORNING YEAH. YEAH
YEAH THERE WAS NO- FOR HIM HE
HAS ANYBODY'S EVERYONE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. OUR CULTURAL
CENTER. FROM THE COMING UP HERE
THE PHONE. YEAH YEAH. OKAY YOU
KNOW YOU LIKE CAMPAIGN LIKE
SOMEBODY WALKS OKAY I THINK IT
WOULD. YEAH. YEAH YEAH. RIGHT
THANK YOU. THE PROPOSAL THIS
WEEK THAT. THE COFFEE MANAGER
LIKE US ON OUR LIKE AND. JUST
LIKE WHAT IS TODAY. I THANK YEAH
YEAH YEAH- AT THAT. SAME YEAH
SINCE YEAH K. YEAH. RIGHT YEAH
RIGHT NOW ALL THE. YEAH. THE
WORKERS OF THIS MEDICAL CONTROL. ONE MILLION. YEAH YEAH YEAH.
WELL I MEAN OTHER THAN THAT-
THANKS. YEAH YEAH. YEAH YEAH THE
- YEAH WELL YEAH- SO. YEAH IN
FACT WHY I IT IS. PLEASE
STRUCTURE. SHE ADDED. YOU COULD
DO THAT- YEAH- YEAH. IN THIS
CASE EQUAL.
ALL THE BILLS OKAY SO WE WILL DO
ADD ONS FOR MISS FRIEDMAN
STARTING FROM THE TOP. I ITEM
ONE AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT. ALL RIGHT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO UTILITIES
AND ENERGY SHAREHOLDING AYE
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I ELECT HAS
LEFT THAT BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES
IT'S OUT. I AM TOO SORRY AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SIX. DEPRESSED
EDUCATION GERALDINE I FRIEDMAN
RIGHT FRIEDMAN HI HAS TEN STILL
HAS TEN BOTH WITHOUT ITEM THREE
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE. DO
PASSAGE TO SHERRY FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I THAT HAS ELEVEN
THOUGH STILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES
WITHOUT. I DON'T. BY FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX OH ONE. DIVEST
REVERBERATIONS SHAREHOLDING I
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE THAT
HAS A BILL HAS A BOTH THE TOP.
RIGHT SIX AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRMAN DENIEDFRIEDMAN. I LOVE IT. THE BILL
HAS ELEVEN VOTES THAT BILLS OUT
. I AM NINE AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN OTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
CORPORATIONS CHAIR VOTING AYE
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I THAT HAS A
BOAT SO THEY BOTH ITS OUT ITEM
TEN AB TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN. DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING AYE
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I THAT HAS
ELEVEN WILL HAVE ELEVEN VOTES
OUT OF ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY
NINE TEN MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY CHAIR
VOTING AYE FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN
I THINK PEOPLE STILL HAS A BOTH
ITS OUT. AB EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
WICKS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY CHAIR VOTING I
FRIEDMAN. AYE FRIEDMAN AYE HE
PROVES BILL HAS ABLE TO TOUT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
MURATSUCHI TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING AYE
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I LIVE IN THE
BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES IT OUT. AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY NINE
DEPRESSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I.
CONCEPTUAL THEN NOW THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MICHAEL WELL THE BILL
HAD NINE VOTES IT'S OUT AND NEXT
CONSENT CALENDAR FRIEDMAN RIGHT
FRIEDMAN I LOVE IT BILL HAS A
LET MEAN CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
ELEVEN VOTES IT'S OUT AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED. THANK. MY CURRENT
KIND OF. WHAT.